Tim Ferriss: Matthew. Matty.
Matt Mullenweg: Yep.
Tim Ferriss: Dr. Mullenweg.
Matt Mullenweg: Not a doctor. At all.
Tim Ferriss: In my heart of
hearts, you're always a doctor.
Matt Mullenweg: I think in Argentina
I got an honorary degree, actually.
Tim Ferriss: Really?
Matt Mullenweg: In that country.
Tim Ferriss: I'm so jelly. Argentina.
I haven't been back in a hundred years,
but we're not here to talk about my
aspirations and dreams, although, maybe.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, I hope to hear some.
Tim Ferriss: Well, we'll dive in and out.
Bob and weave. For people who don't have
context on the Argentine Dr. Mullenweg,
could you give people just a snapshot?
Matt Mullenweg: Sure. Matt Mullenweg,
domain ma.tt, which is pretty fun.
Tim Ferriss: Excellent domain.
Matt Mullenweg: I got my domain at .TT
sometimes. Born and raised in Houston,
Texas, a few hours from here, in Austin.
At the age of 19, I co-founded open source
software called WordPress, which is a blogging
content management system. Fast-forward 20 years,
it's been 20 years now, and runs over a third of
all websites in the world. A few years after that,
I co-founded or founded a company called
Automattic, which is kind of like the for-profit
side of commercializing things around WordPress.
Tim Ferriss: Auto-Matt-ic, M-A-T-T?
Matt Mullenweg: Yes. It's like any egotistical
founder, I snuck my name into the company
and we started with just sort of Akismet
anti-spam and wordpress.com kind of easy
ways to get going with WordPress, but since
have expanded to e-commerce with WooCommerce,
one I'll talk about with messaging, we've done a
number, over 25 acquisitions, so we're trying to
be a digital Berkshire Hathaway, like a buyer of
first resort for amazing things on the internet.
Pretty much everything we do is open source or
open web. Oh, we bought Tumblr, so we're running
Tumblr for the last few years, basically trying
to — I would like future generations to grow up
with a web that is more open, more free, gives
more liberty, and so open source is really my
life's work, even above WordPress and anything
else. I hope to work on it the rest of my life.
Tim Ferriss: You are one of the rare examples,
and I'm so envious of this particular sort of
mental state of focus that you have, which is
this clarity on what you want to do, something
you could do for the rest of your life with that
degree of certainty. It's something that's always
struck me as rare and maybe not as a consequence
of being rare but precious in a sense. Anyway, I'm
happy for you. I don't run across that much from
a professional perspective, when someone's like,
"I want to do this for the rest of my life."
Matt Mullenweg: I think it's because the open
source freedom and liberty's somewhat abstract, so
there could be lots of things under that. In fact
I just mentioned probably too many things.
Some people will call me very unfocused,
but you have that too. We talked about it on
the last podcast around teaching, learning,
education, lifelong — that's the rest of your
life. I think if you can find those principles,
you can keep them and then the job might
change, other things might change. I'm lucky
to work at the same job because I'm probably
unemployable anywhere else at this point,
but it's been a lot of fun. Oh, Automattic's now
over 1,900 people in 97 countries. We were fully
remote and distributed since 2005, so we've
been kind of early on a few of those trends,
open source, distributed, et cetera.
Tim Ferriss: I know we've talked about
this before and you've certainly talked about it
in other places, but we're going to get into a
lot of new territory, before we do that though,
open source, just for people who may not have
familiarity with that term, what does that mean?
Matt Mullenweg: Normally when you sign up for
software, you click through that license that no
one ever reads. Ours actually has Easter eggs in
it just to see if anyone will find them. Most
of those licenses are about all the rights you
don't have. Sometimes you're not even allowed to
look at the thing and see how it works. There's
a whole right to repair movement right now
where you can buy things that you're not even
allowed to repair yourself. Open source is the
opposite. It's all about almost like a bill of
rights for you as the user. WordPress belongs
just as much to Tim Ferriss as it does to me,
which is kind of amazing. There's rights and
freedoms you have to use it for any purpose,
to modify it, to see how it works, all these sorts
of things that no one can take away from you.
Even myself as a co-founder, or even if all the
other developers got together, and we all agreed
to become evil, we couldn't take it away from you.
It's that bill of rights, those inalienable rights
is the core of open source and there's lots
of examples. Wikipedia is open source applied
to an encyclopedia. It used to be really bad and
Encarta, Encyclopedia Britannica were way better,
but then over time lots of people working together
made it better and better. Why did they work
on it? For free, for fun, and also because it
belongs to them. WordPress has many thousands,
probably tens of thousands of contributors at
this point. Why do they do that? Is it Tom Sawyer
painting the fence or is it the other guy?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I need more
caffeine to be on my literary references.
Matt Mullenweg: We should both know that. Wow,
I'm embarrassed for both of us. Tom Sawyer,
and — it'll be the first thing in the comments.
Tim Ferriss: Huckleberry Finn.
Matt Mullenweg: Huckleberry Finn,
yeah. It's because it actually belongs to
people. Sometimes people come in and just
fix one bug that's annoying them. Or sometimes you
have the pride of knowing that code you wrote is
running on a third of all websites in the world,
which is actually a real thrill as an engineer
developer, and that's just a lot of fun.
Tim Ferriss: It's openly collaborative in
that way. Not to state the obvious, but it's
a contrast to actually this news item I saw
in — "news" is probably giving it a little bit
too much gravitas — but I read this story which
seemed credible based on the source, I'm not
going to give it too much, but this engineer
joins a startup and fixes one or two bugs
or develops a feature that he wanted in the
product and then put in notice and that was it.
Matt Mullenweg: Two weeks later, yeah. I love
that story because I know so many on the spectrum
of engineers that would totally do that. It's a
beautiful hack, right, where, "Oh, I've just got
to get this fixed." There's actually companies
I would do that. One thing I have considered is
secret shopping, seeing if I could get hired by
my own company under a fake identity or just
something like that. It would be kind of fun.
Tim Ferriss: Why would you do that?
Matt Mullenweg: One, to experience the
hiring process, which is difficult for me to
debug. It's set by secondhand accounts. Two,
to see how my code still is.
Tim Ferriss: Do companies provide
mystery shopper-like services for hiring
processes or no, because mystery shoppers,
this would be the equivalent of, say, retail
where there are companies you can hire,
they send people into stores to experience the
touch points and the flow or lack of flow and
then to report back so you can improve your
operations, and you have that for security,
right? You can hire people to red team and
try to exploit or defeat your security and
then you get a report back and you
can improve things. Does that exist
for something like a hiring process?
Matt Mullenweg: It probably does,
but I'm a big believer in, especially executives,
going and doing the work themselves. Engaging with
the customers, doing customer support, trying out
the product, building a website, whatever it is
that your thing is. I think that's so key.
Tim Ferriss: I might be making this up,
but something along the lines of two
weeks of frontline service. Even if
it's a CFO or someone who's —
Matt Mullenweg: No matter the
job you're hired for at Automattic,
you start with two weeks of support,
and then every single person rotates back in one
week per year, and I'm running out of year, so I'm
actually squeezing mine in at the very end here.
If you go to wordpress.com support in the next two
weeks, you might get me. I talked to executives
at Salesforce, I was really impressed. They were
saying they spend 50 percent of their time with
customers. This was a top executive running an
organization of thousands of people. I was like,
wow, that's inspiring to me. I'm probably 25 or
30 percent right now. So it really made me think,
am I spending enough time with customers? Also,
we might have some executives that are spending
closer to zero percent time. How do we make
this a cultural thing throughout the company?
Tim Ferriss: You're an enthusiastic fellow.
Part of why I like spending time with you. Good
vibes, lots of smiles, lots of laughs. You also
find a lot of things that are interesting out
at the edges and you're an immaculate packer of
bags also. For those who do not know "What's in My
Bag" every year gives the latest and greatest of
Matt's tech gadgetry and assorted doodads and
doohickeys that he's traveling with as a road
warrior who travels, fair to say, most of the
time. Your schedule, we're going to get to my
first planned question in a second. I recall maybe
it was five months ago, six months ago, who knows,
you sent me something along the lines of just in
case we can overlap, here's where I'll be in the
next year, and it was one of the most absurd, it
was like a Rolling Stones tour. Are you continuing
to do that in terms of travel for the next year?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, currently. Why do I go into
it? Well, it's a global community, so one, I have
a global company and a global community. Our hack
for Automattic, because we're apart most of the
year, is the teams get together a couple times
a year. If you're an individual contributor, you
might travel two, three times a year. But as CEO,
this means that every week there's a couple of
meetups happening and I try to hit the bigger
ones and sometimes the small ones too, but mostly
the really big ones where there's a couple hundred
people there, but that's happening at least once
a month. Then for WordPress, there's three major
work camps per year that have thousands of
people. There's all these different — I just
did State of the Word in Madrid. You just take
those, you're traveling a week out of the month
already, and then you got to add in some fun.
Tim Ferriss: You're not going to die of a fun
deficiency, you know how to have fun.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, it really adds up. But,
it does take more of a toll than it used to,
I've got to be totally honest. There were years
I did well over 400,000 miles and looking back
I was like, I don't know if I still have some
of the energy or I'm getting more radiation in the
plane. I don't know, maybe I'm just getting older.
Tim Ferriss: That does happen to people.
Matt Mullenweg: 40 in a few weeks.
Tim Ferriss: I know. Thank God. No more of this 30
under 30, 40 under 40 nonsense. You've accumulated
700 lifetimes worth of those. You mentioned
gatherings and the first, I suppose, cone that
we're going to weave around on this slalom of
a conversation is things that are exciting you,
things you're excited about, five or more. I enjoy
this format. It's very simple. I haven't done
it much and it's a shame because I always have a
good time doing it. Where would you like to start?
Matt Mullenweg: Well, I mentioned messaging. If
you look at Automattic's history, it was like
2005. Blogging CMS, 2016 Commerce, Blue Commerce,
it's grown to over 30 billion of sales or GMV. We
entered our third major area this year, which was
messaging. We acquired this company called Texts.
You might remember these sorts of programs, but
we all have 20 different messaging apps. Texts
currently takes 10 of them. It'll take more
in the future. Signal, WhatsApp, Telegram,
Facebook Messenger, Instagram Messenger, Twitter
DMs, all these sorts of things, some of which have
terrible interfaces. It brings them into one power
user app right now, desktop only because it's all
ultra secure so it doesn't break any encryption
or run anything in the cloud. It's all on your
device, which is I think very, very important.
Engineers, you have a code of ethics. I think
we need to build things extra secure now. It
brings them all together. It's really nice.
I often acquire apps or invest in things
to make up for my own deficiencies. Like
investing in Calm in 2012 or whatever it was, I
felt like I needed to meditate. I was so behind
on messages. I'm like, "Okay, we've got to
buy this company and make it available."
Tim Ferriss: It's like a much more expensive
version of the guy who gets hired and fixes
the bugs and then leaves. Buying companies.
Matt Mullenweg: A small team, really, really
exciting. I'd love for you to try it, actually.
Tim Ferriss: My team is using it and they love it.
Matt Mullenweg: That's right. [BLEEP]
actually told me about this even before
I had heard about it myself. Some credit there.
Tim Ferriss: The team's loving it. I have used
it and it is a great product. Where can
people find it or learn more about it?
Matt Mullenweg: Texts.com. T-E-X-T-S dot com.
Tim Ferriss: Texts.com. All right. Texts.com.
Matt Mullenweg: If you go on desktop and it's
a paid product right now, so 15 bucks a month,
five bucks a month if you're a student or pretend
to be a student, but we're also going to explore
some different things. Mobile app is coming out
next year in the early part and we're going to
explore some different pricing as well. Maybe
making it free for one or two networks paid for
more. That's some very exciting stuff there.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so I want to ask you
a strategy question to the extent that you can
discuss it. You were kind enough to spend a lot
of time with me just as a friend overall, which
I really appreciate, love spending time with you,
and also just because disclosures are important.
I am available at your beck and call, advisor with
Automattic from the early days. I am fascinated
by not just how you operate in the world,
but how you think about the world because
that's a prerequisite for making a lot of,
not necessarily contrarian because you can be a
different form of sheep as a contrarian too by
just doing the opposite of what everyone
else does. That's easy. But picking and
choosing where you're going to be unorthodox or
approach things obliquely is more challenging.
The question, and I'm going to set the table
with some other examples, but the question
is how you choose what you're going to get into
in terms of areas, products, et cetera, because
there's diversification, there's lack of focus,
there's synergy, these words we can throw around.
I would love to know how you think about, for
instance, or thought about getting into commerce,
which I think is a more obvious leap in my mind
than say messaging. What I've observed is say in
the media landscape, well the media landscape and
the social media platform landscapes have collided
in such a major way in the last five to 10 years
where you have Amazon Studios, you've got Netflix,
you've got messaging, and then video and so on
that are seemingly all being pursued on some
level by a lot of these large platforms. In the
forms of, say WhatsApp or whatever it might be.
How do you choose what to engage in
next? You said some people might say,
"I'm unfocused," I don't consider you
unfocused, but there are sometimes hidden
or unspoken rationales or logics behind. How do
you think about what you're going to do next?
Matt Mullenweg: I do think about it for a long
time. We've been thinking about messaging and
actually making investments in this space for four
or five years. I think a lot about environment and
incentives. The reason there used to be these
multi-messaging apps 15 years ago and they all
stopped working was the networks all blocked
them. There is a political environment now
which I think is more conducive to being more
customer and user-centric. This is our data,
this is our messages, it's all secure,
it's not breaking security or anything,
so why shouldn't we be able to run this.
Tim Ferriss: Can you give an example of a network
blocking these multi-message tools in the past?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, it happened last week.
There was another one called Beeper that
supported iMessage and Apple decided to
just shut it down. They broke it all and Beeper
actually charged its users. They had to refund
everyone. It's also more subtle things they
could do. They could just subtly degrade if
they make it so your messages don't go through
five percent of the time, it's not blocking you,
but you're going to stop using it.
Tim Ferriss: It's like throttling
your hotel speed on Wi-Fi. So you upgrade to
the premium, you're like, "Okay, all right."
Matt Mullenweg: They don't need to block
you, which might draw attention. They can
just make you a little wobbly.
Tim Ferriss: More painful.
Matt Mullenweg: It doesn't take a lot of friction
for people to move away, especially in messaging.
The regulatory framework, both with the
EU doing a lot of sometimes misguided,
but also sometimes really smart, they have
an act coming in called the DMA that requires
some interop between messaging services. We
will talk about USB-C, which I'm very excited
about. Thank you EU, for forcing Apple to
finally drop lightning and give us USB-C.
Then in the US I think there is bipartisan, this
I actually don't agree with, but it is a reality,
some extra scrutiny on big tech. I think it's
actually good for them. Again, what are their
incentives? I think it's actually really good for
them to show that they're open right now. I don't
want to fight these folks. They've got more
money than most countries. They could squash
us like a bug if they really, really wanted
to, but we're always doing things open source,
user-centric, and so it's —
Tim Ferriss: It'd be a
bad look for them to try to squash.
Matt Mullenweg: If you have the people on your
side, I feel like that's what truly matters in
long-term. People are what, short-term, lobbying,
et cetera, but long-term in the US, functioning
democracy, politics is accountable to its people.
Tim Ferriss: If we come back to what you said and
the whole point of this format is scaffolding,
and then we can deviate. We're deviating right
now. People may have noticed. Talking about a,
let's just say next, next gen or digital Berkshire
Hathaway. Berkshire Hathaway could have, well,
originally textiles, but they
could have insurance, then they
could have something that is —
Matt Mullenweg: Chocolates.
Tim Ferriss: Chocolates, right? See's Candies,
things that are completely unrelated on a
face-value business level. They're not integrated
in the way that a CMS or having a gajillion
blogs and websites running on your platform
would combine very easily with WooCommerce,
right? Those two pair very nicely. Are you
thinking about, say in the case of texts.com
that is a standalone in the same way that some of
these Berkshire Hathaway might be a standalone?
How do you think about building and acquiring in
that way? Are they standalones? How much do they
need to help each other or not? In the case of
Berkshire, right, the insurance premiums and so
on, as I understand it, provide a huge bolus of
cash for all sorts of other purposes. The capital
can be utilized across the family, in a sense.
How do you think about, because there's so many
different ways you could rank order the priorities
when looking at potential acquisitions, is it just
like customer pain point, converging trend lines
in terms of regulation and public sentiment and —
Matt Mullenweg: Which Berkshire navigates
beautifully in highly regulated industries,
including insurance, railways. How I think
about it, I like to study these people. I
know you love doing that too. Study high
performers, that's your thing, right?
Tim Ferriss: I do that sometimes.
Yeah, occasionally do that.
Matt Mullenweg: I mean, Charlie Munger, rest
in peace, 99 years old. Warren Buffett, I don't
know exactly. I think up there as well. I try to
think if Warren Buffett and Charlie Munger were
hackers in their 30s or 40s today, what would they
build versus what they built in their time with
the opportunities in technology afforded? I like
to think they do some open source because it's,
obviously, the future. I like the Berkshire for
atoms companies versus — atoms versus bits — and
in the industries, they're in —
Tim Ferriss: A-T-O-M-S.
Matt Mullenweg: I think there would be a lot of
coordination costs and they try to optimize for
giving the companies under them as much autonomy
as possible. They find great leaders and they also
try to find great businesses. I think Warren
Buffett said something like, "We try to find
a business a monkey could run, because someday
they will," something like that. What business
is so good, it would survive even bad leadership.
What we do with a digital version of that is we
lower coordination costs between the different
products by open source. They don't need, like
For WooCommerce, to build on top of WordPress.
It doesn't need a meeting, doesn't need to talk,
doesn't even to know the people developing
WordPress. There's open APIs, open source,
there's a plugin framework, et cetera. That
removes a lot of the coordination costs that
you normally get in a multi division company.
Tim Ferriss: Now when you say coordination costs,
are you talking about people internally, say,
full-time employees? Or are you talking about the
communities that surround some of these things?
Matt Mullenweg: In proprietary software,
if you want to integrate with something, like if I
wanted to add a new feature to Mac OS or something
like that, I can't do that. Now, they have APIs,
they have operating systems. Smart companies like
Slack or Shopify will create marketplaces that
you can extend them. However, you're subject
to their terms so they can change their mind.
Remember Twitter used to have all those clients,
or Facebook did too. They were like, "Oh, we
don't want this anymore. You're all kicked off."
Tim Ferriss: Rough Tuesday.
Matt Mullenweg: Don't build on
proprietary platforms. They can pull the rug and
will pull the rug at any point. In open source,
one, the rug can't be pulled. Two,
typically they're ultra pluggable.
You can really change every line of WordPress.
Tim Ferriss: Not to interrupt, but would you
mind giving a real world example of what this
lowered integration cost looks like in practice?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah. Let's talk about a
company like Salesforce, which has done a ton
of acquisitions. One criticism of a Salesforce
or Cisco or even Google: sometimes their own
products don't integrate with each other as well.
Sometimes even external things do. So even with
the best acquisitions, and most acquisitions fail
by the way, even when you do a really good one,
maybe say YouTube, sometimes the integrations
aren't as strong. Remember when YouTube tried
to do the Google+ thing?
Tim Ferriss: I do.
Matt Mullenweg: Every single division in Google
was incentivized by how much adoption Google+
got. They really tried to push it into
everything. A lot of coordination costs,
maybe not as responsive to users. That was
ultimately an unsuccessful push. Google's
another example. All the messaging platforms
they have, you need text just to work with the
five messaging platforms at Google. There's
examples like that where you get duplication,
you get different incentives of executives, maybe
they're more rewarded for launching new things
versus integrating things. Those are coordination
costs. This comes up in economics terms where
why shouldn't everyone just be a freelancer?
Well, there's some coordination costs there.
It's nice to have people employed full-time by a
company. Then you don't need to rehire them every
time. They're not going to be poached by someone
else. Maybe you have a gap in the gig and they
just take another gig, that sort of thing. I feel
like for us, the common platform of open source,
particularly WordPress, allows us to plug things
in and do acquisitions in a way that is more set
up for success. We have a set of products that
run directly on WordPress or get distribution
from WordPress and Tumblr. That's, I would
say, our core area. There are some which are,
I would call, philosophically adjacent.
It's the same philosophy. Day One is
a great example. Day One doesn't share
any technology with Tumblr or WordPress,
but it's a fully encrypted local journaling
app. Journaling is another word for blogging.
You can use it like I do as a local blog. I
posted every day for the past 200 or 300 days.
Tim Ferriss: What does "local blog" mean?
To the untrained ear, they'd be like, "Wait,
so I have a blog that I'm publishing on
my own computer? How do people see it?"
Matt Mullenweg: Well, this is why people usually
call it a journal. But when you think about it,
like a "notes" app, like the Notes app, I
don't know, typically things are undated,
right? The metadata associated with them is
somewhat loose. Often the list is ordered by
most recently modified. That's kind of a UI. In
a blog, it's reverse chronological. We have a lot
of metadata associated. Day One attaches a date,
location, we can store the weather when you post
it. All these different things that kind of make
it a bit richer. When it's local, we usually call
it a journal, just because that's the concept.
Apple just launched a built-in journaling app.
I call it a blog because fundamentally if you
kind of look at those principles, it's got all
the same ingredients as you post a blog reverse
chronological. Now why do I really like it? I
prefer dated entries because I'm usually taking
notes each day. Kind of like Benjamin Franklin. He
would log everything he does every day. I do that
as well. I love the search, I love tagging, I love
all those metadata things. Help me find stuff. You
can also interlink the notes, which is actually
pretty cool. Not unlike a Roam Research or some of
these other — Obsidian. You can interlink things.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so we took a
little side alley if we come back
to things that you're excited about.
Matt Mullenweg: I didn't actually
answer your question on messaging.
Tim Ferriss: You did not, yes.
Matt Mullenweg: So why messaging? It is not
built on top of WordPress and it's not part
of our publishing kind of thing, but I do believe
it is fundamental human right to have private and
hopefully in the future, open source messaging.
Again, I only want to work on things I feel
like I can work on potentially the rest of my
life. So publishing commerce and messaging,
that covers a lot of human activity.
Tim Ferriss: It does.
Matt Mullenweg: And if you have those things
truly free, I think you have a free society.
And that's also exciting to me because how do
we help bend the long arc towards more freedom,
more liberty across the world? And technology does
that better than, I think, any sort of diplomacy
or anything else that at least I could work on.
Tim Ferriss: Are there any other people or
companies that stand out as being
aligned or philosophically adjacent
with the ethos you're describing?
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, yeah. Well, one,
there's a lot more open source companies now.
GitLab is a really great one led by Sid. They're
actually even more open than we are. They publish
like everything and they're a public company now,
like nine or $10 billion. So that's pretty
cool to have those examples. I think Element,
which is built on the Matrix ecosystem,
so open source messaging, actually the
competitor to text Beeper, really awesome
company, I think philosophically very aligned.
So what's cool is more and more of this is
happening. Also, there's a fun trend where
sometimes people who did proprietary companies
and then made a ton of money off them, what
they do next is often open source. So Jack Dorsey
made him a ton of money off Twitter, Square. One,
he's taken Square to more of a crypto direction.
He wants to enable that. And two, what's he
funding? Something called Nostr and Bluesky, which
are two competing open source Twitters, which is
really cool. Brian Acton, co-founder of WhatsApp.
What's he doing today? He's running Signal,
which is an open source nonprofit messaging app,
which is amazing. Signal, very philosophically
aligned. So Wikipedia, Mozilla, there's a
lot out there both for-profit and nonprofit.
Tim Ferriss: Based on the very little I know, and
you track this type of thing much more than I do,
but in terms of number of users per
full-time employee pre acquisition,
how would you place WhatsApp? I mean, it's —
Matt Mullenweg: The messaging apps are tops.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: I think Instagram
was a pretty good size with 13 or 14 when they
sold. Telegram's actually pretty amazing today.
Signal is pretty small team. I'm not sure the
size of the WhatsApp team now, but they were very,
very small when they were acquired. It's actually
pretty incredible because messaging — there's not
really any user support. It's all self-serve.
And so those businesses can scale quite a bit
with very few people and it also attracts
really amazing engineer. The Texts team is
incredible. And so their aspiration is to remain
a sub-20, sub-30 team, even as they grow to tens
of millions or hundreds of millions of users.
Tim Ferriss: So how do you, as the buyer first
resort, hopefully the aspiring buyer, first
resort, Berkshire Hathaway, known as Automattic,
how do you find these various companies or threads
to pull on or how do those people find you?
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, people do reach out
sometimes, which is always nice. But yeah,
I guess fundamentally it's usually just driven by
me as a user. I'm always trying out new products,
friends recommend it. My colleagues actually,
of the people we employ, they tend to be very
early adopters and very digitally savvy. So
I mean, that's why we launched Bitcoin in
2012 when it was $12. I wish I could say that
that was me being brilliant. No, it was one of
my colleagues who was like, "Oh, this thing's
so cool, we can add support." And I think he
hacked it over a weekend, and so, all right, cool.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. I'll tell you just a quick
anecdote that I haven't mentioned really. I don't
know, I haven't mentioned it anywhere because why
would I? But you mentioned Charlie Munger, rest
in peace. I was, if I'm remembering correctly,
I mean I was definitely tentatively scheduled, I
think it was to interview him the next Tuesday.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, my goodness.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: He had just started doing podcasts
for the first time.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Matt Mullenweg: He did the one with
the Collisons, right? John Patrick
— or Invest Like the Best, I think.
Tim Ferriss: He did, I think it was
Acquired. I can't recall exactly.
Matt Mullenweg: But we'll link
it up. It was a really great episode.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. So for people who didn't get
a chance, we'll link to that in the show notes.
Matt Mullenweg: I appreciated that when he passed,
for someone who I've been so obsessed
with for many years, when he passed,
I actually had a feeling of wow, what a life
well lived and so appreciative how much he's
published over the years. So even though he hadn't
done a lot of these podcasts or modern stuff,
he has been doing the meetings and speeches and
other things for decades now. So you don't always
have to meet your mentors. I think you talk about
that as well. Sometimes it's really great to just
have the book or the speech or something like
that and it can really live with you. You can
grow up with it, you can reread it over the years,
like rereading Siddhartha. I know you have some
things that you read. Is it Zorba the Greek?
Tim Ferriss: Zorba the Greek is spectacular.
I think we might've been together.
Matt Mullenweg: When you found that book.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, in Greece, when I
found that book of all places, in Greece,
in Santorini. And absolutely loved that book, yes.
So that is one I go back to revisit. There are a
lot of books I go back to revisit, Awareness by
Anthony de Mello would be another one, very short,
very fast. I'm increasingly a fan of rereading,
that includes some fiction too, as you mentioned,
Zorba the Greek. Any books you reread?
Matt Mullenweg: Siddhartha.
Tim Ferriss: Why? Great cover.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, just an interesting story
of enlightenment and journey and it's
actually my Twitter bio is, "I can think,
I can wait, I can fast."
Tim Ferriss: That's a
great line. Something like that, yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: I probably have it out of order,
but I do them out of order too, so it
works. What else do I like to reread?
Essays for sure, Paul Graham.
Tim Ferriss: Which essays?
Matt Mullenweg: "Acceleration of
Addictiveness" is a really good one.
Tim Ferriss: I haven't read that one.
Matt Mullenweg: He has one on speed. He
just published what I consider his magnum opus,
apparently worked on it for a year. I think it's
called "How to Do Great Work" or something like
that. Man, that one's really good. That could be a
book. Yeah, it's interesting that there is authors
now blogging essentially, publishing these essays
like Slate Star Codex, Scott Alexander, Shane
Parrish, Knowledge Project. There's these writers
now that really drive a lot of folks. I mean,
your WordPress blog started that genre in a lot
of ways, like the longer form, like super essays.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, a thousand plus blog
posts, a lot of blog posts. And it's sometimes
easy for me to forget that that was essential
for the entire, I don't know if I would call it
trajectory, meandering, developing "career" that
I've had. Without the blog, it doesn't happen.
I mean the blog was started before the first
book. It continued — I mean it still continues,
But I have a question for you related to blogging
actually. And then ultimately led to the podcast,
but without the blog, very hard to drive people
to the podcast and show notes.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So the blog was both jet fuel and
bridge and connective tissue and still continues
to be. I have thought a lot about next chapters
for myself recently. I love doing the podcast. I
plan on continuing doing the podcast. The
10th anniversary is coming up next April.
Matt Mullenweg: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: 10 years of,
on average, 1.4 episodes per week every
week. It's been going for a long time.
Matt Mullenweg: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: And I wasn't the
first podcaster, nor will I be the last, but 10
years is a good stretch and it's an opportunity to
pause and reflect, think about things. And when I
was doing that recently, it's the end of the year,
I noticed that often I enter a game that is new.
I'm not the first participant, so I'm not at the
absolute cutting edge, but I'm on the sharp edge.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, yeah. Pretty early.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, pretty early. And then
I stick around for a while and I focus on
it with incredible enthusiasm and OCD.
Matt Mullenweg: Ridiculous intensity.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, intensity. And then
it often gets a bit crowded or saturated,
and then I do something else.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So that was true a bit with the blog,
but it wasn't so much that blogging got crowded,
but other opportunities surfaced. And then
there was the startup investing and then that
was a focus from, say, 2008 to 2015. Then I took
a hiatus for a while. I took a startup vacation,
took a complete break from that. That was in
tandem with books, took a break from the books
after The 4-Hour Chef, that's when the podcast
was started, 2014. Have done that for a while.
And now I'm looking at various trends, various
types of collective and individual behavior.
I'm like, "Okay, there's a lot more zero-sum
behavior. Things are getting very saturated,
things are much more algorithmically driven
now." So you can effectively have an attention
rug pull where you're pursuing format X and
all of a sudden format X becomes invisible.
That could be long-form audio. Then you get pushed
to video and then you get pushed to short video,
then you get pushed to clips and now you're
in reels, but you're not appearing where you
used to appear, etc, etc. And I've been thinking
about what to do next and have posed the question
to some folks, I'd be curious to get your two
cents, maybe we'll talk about it over dinner
tonight is what you would find interesting for
me to do next. And part of what's baked into
that is as was true with these early chapters
in each of these new arenas, where do I have a
particular differentiator, an ability or access
or combination in some weird Venn diagram that
gives me an advantage? That was true with the
startups because I had the blog actually. I
had the platform and the visibility through the
first book, which allowed me to become an advisor
with various companies and that was what enabled
that as well as geographically being located in —
Matt Mullenweg: Bay Area.
Tim Ferriss: Bay Area.
Matt Mullenweg: Although some
cool companies like Shopify or us,
which were not really Bay Area companies.
Tim Ferriss: That's true, that's true. And
actually a lot of my greatest hits are from,
they are from outside of the Bay Area. Being
in the Bay Area created a certain high level of
resonance with discussion in those communities,
which then extended to places like
Ottawa. What I've been also thinking,
this is getting a little long, but I really
respect your opinion on all this stuff and
I know you pay close attention is that the new
thing isn't always a new thing. So for instance,
I was chatting, I'm not going to name him
because he probably doesn't want to be named,
but I was chatting with a friend of
mine and he came back to writing.
He was like, "You can write." And he's
like, "Everyone has a TV show now,
effectively." If you want to have a podcast, you
are building out a studio. And the truth of the
matter is people are really good, really good. I
mean there are some spectacularly well-produced,
well-organized, well-researched, well-executed
shows out there and it's going to get more
crowded. I mean you can use, for instance
right now, you can go to ChatGPT and say,
"Provide me with 10 questions in the flavor of
Andrew Huberman, Tim Ferriss, Rich Roll, pick your
favorite podcaster, if he or she were interviewing
so-and-so," and it will spit out questions.
And they are quite good. They're not bad.
Matt Mullenweg: That's hilarious actually.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, right. So if you have notes in
front of you and you're presentable on camera or
via audio, now you're a formidable competitor.
The hurdles used to be a little higher,
it used to be a little harder. So I've thought
about going back to writing, it is very high
labor. There's a reason there's so many podcasters
in the sense when COVID hit, people could have all
become writers. When the writer's strike happened,
people could have all become writers. Writing
is really, really difficult, I think, so —
Matt Mullenweg: I'll interject here if I can.
Tim Ferriss: Interject.
Matt Mullenweg: Also, I felt like your
writing process had a lot of solitary.
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Matt Mullenweg: And what I observed
as you got more into podcasting,
other things is you really loved the —
Tim Ferriss: The social piece.
Matt Mullenweg: — social piece of it, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: The interpersonal, like the
direct you and I sitting across
from a table in a personal piece.
Matt Mullenweg: It's more of a team doing
it. Also, there's this with the guest and —
Tim Ferriss: 100 percent.
Matt Mullenweg: — that's
actually a pretty cool element of the format.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. That's a huge piece.
You're totally right. And I think there's part
of me that has recognized how nourishing that
is for me. And I'm hesitant to go back into
monk mode in the cave staring at a blank page.
I don't know, do you have any thoughts that
percolate? We can certainly continue this,
I'm just wondering. I mean, at the very least
this is just like a confessional, which is nice.
Matt Mullenweg: No, I love that. I love
psychoanalyzing Tim. It's one of my pastimes.
That is a good question. And I think how you laid
out how the market changes and becomes crowded is
very, very true. So the thoughts that come to mind
is first, also just as your friend, I would love
to see you focus on things where it's not just
outcome based. Because as you talked about this,
you're like, "What about the traffic?" Those are
my outcomes. So where are there things? And I
think actually podcasting is true for this, where
the journey itself is very rewarding for you.
Tim Ferriss: Totally.
Matt Mullenweg: If no one listened to this,
this was still a fun afternoon.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely.
Matt Mullenweg: And we're just recording
what we might do anyway, which is neat.
Tim Ferriss: Best job ever.
Matt Mullenweg: So I think that's
nice. So I would say, I think actually I find
writing, although it can be unfun at the time,
so rewarding afterwards.
Tim Ferriss: Type two fun.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, type two fun. And so I
wonder as well if that's — I'm not sure how
much you're writing right now. I know you did
some fiction stuff and some comic stuff and so
that's interesting.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Those questions of creativity.
Tim Ferriss: And those also, when I bleed out
of nonfiction is when it gets easier for me
to collaborate, which maybe is the way I go,
not necessarily fiction per se, but just different
formats. That would be an ability to experiment. I
mean the other thing is, and I'm not going to have
the right attribution, maybe it's Neil Strauss,
maybe it's Seth Godin, but anyone who's really
been consistently productive in the sense of
words on pages, the vast majority, at some point
I've heard say, "There's no such thing as writer's
block. It's when your standards are too high.
You just need to lower your standards until
you can get out of rough draft." And I'm of course
grossly generalizing, but it's along those lines.
And so I've also thought, I think part of the
reason that writing is so intimidating to me is
I look at some of my blog posts and they're not
quite Tim Urban, God bless his soul, they're not
50,000-word posts, but they're long. I mean these
are significant investments of time and energy.
And maybe the answer is, "You know what? Just you
can't write more than four paragraphs. That's it."
Matt Mullenweg: Some constraints.
Tim Ferriss: Closer to, say, some of Seth's
shorter pieces. Even shorter, much shorter than
Paul Graham. I'll give a nod to Paul also. I have,
I think, it's "The Top Idea in Your Mind" that
is one of his essays that I have bookmarked so
it's visible in my browser. There are others
of course, I mean the "Maker's Schedule,
Manager's Schedule," or "Manager's Schedule,
Maker's Schedule," which I think is a perennial
reminder worth paying attention to. So I've
thought about the constraints, maybe making it
shorter, but I do think to underscore what
you said, the social piece is a big one.
Matt Mullenweg: How do you make it social?
So if I were to brainstorm about your blog,
some things I'd recommend trying
are like what would a really amazing
comment section look like? If that were
really jazzed up, maybe more like forums,
maybe more like building community. You've
experimented with events before and I think
that's actually pretty exciting. I found a lot of
value because I've been blogging now for 20 years,
and some gardening, so meaning returning to some
older pieces, some of which still get traffic. And
do the links work? What's the update to it? At the
top, do I link to a new thing? Does this inspire
me to write a new version of this?
Tim Ferriss: That's interesting.
Matt Mullenweg: Really lovely, actually.
It feels like you're creating a corpus,
you're creating a body of work that even the
old stuff reflects some of your best today
thinking and being able to return to the
old Tim or when I return to the old Matt,
it's often sometimes surprising. I'm like, "Wow,
I said this?" Sometimes I'm pleasantly surprised.
Sometimes I'm like, "Ah, I was young." But then
maybe that's a cool grist for something new.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Like, "Hey, I said this 15 years
ago." I'm like, "Wow, I've learned so much since
then," and maybe you're at my 15 ago version. And
here's what changed my mind.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: I guess we have a list of things
to change your mind on, community and also I think
multimodal formats. It's like you're going to
take this podcast and slice it up for TikTok,
Shorts, Reels, whatever you're putting it on. I
think people don't do that enough into blog posts.
Tim Ferriss: Tell me more. What does
that mean? You mean converting things
into blog posts or taking blog posts
and turning them into other derivative –
Matt Mullenweg: No, I think every podcast you
do has 10 to 15 blog posts worth of stuff in it.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I agree.
Matt Mullenweg: Easily.
Tim Ferriss: Easily.
Matt Mullenweg: And so —
Tim Ferriss: I just don't want to — I
mean, you've known me for a long time,
so I'm going to start with my fears. Not all the
amazing ways this could go, let me talk about all
the terrible things that could happen. I guess
what I want to be very cautious of is the siren
song of high volume content farming.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Because I have seen people
who are very good, they're very smart,
but they're really video first, just
churning out just an assembly line of
hot dogs of content in every form,
including text. So how would you
think about quality assurance on that?
Matt Mullenweg: We've actually talked
about this. We brainstormed a bit on your site
around if you imagined Tim.blog, almost like
a Wikipedia where each guest was like a topic
and that could be referred to in many episodes.
And so I think that might be the antidote to
this, to where the content, the transcripts,
everything. How this works on blogs, it's kind of
clunky right now. I think you have a post for the
show and then a post for the —
Tim Ferriss: Transcript.
Matt Mullenweg: — notes script
or transcript. And that should
honestly be one URL, like it should be —
Tim Ferriss: It's clunky. It's clunky in
part because it's a lot of stuff.
The show notes are very extensive.
Matt Mullenweg: They're long.
Tim Ferriss: And then the transcripts are very
extensive. So it turns into an enormous — it's
basically a book. It turns into a book length.
Matt Mullenweg: I would love if the transcript
tied to a player, video and/or audio,
so you can click on it and listen. You
could listen and read at the same time,
sort of like a karaoke scrolling through.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, I use YouTube that
way with transcripts.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah,
they have some cool features there. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Surprisingly good, surprisingly good.
Matt Mullenweg: I would love for everything
to be linked, auto linked. So any time a book
is mentioned, anytime an essay is mentioned,
that goes to a page which pivots. I want to
see every time Paul Graham's been mentioned
across all of your — how many episodes now?
Tim Ferriss: It's close to 700.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah. That's interesting.
Tim Ferriss: I've been invoking
Paul Graham like Candyman, Candyman,
Candyman for years now. But as of yet, we have
not had a podcast conversation. Maybe someday.
Matt Mullenweg: I don't think he does that many.
Tim Ferriss: He does very few. He
had a conversation with Tyler Cowen.
Matt Mullenweg: I love that one, it was hilarious.
Tim Ferriss: Which was hilarious. Which was
hilarious. And I have the utmost respect for
both of those guys. Tyler is also a one
of a kind. He has stylistically produced
a very novel and helpful show. There is no
one like Tyler, he has an inimitable style.
Matt Mullenweg: The rapid-fire question.
Tim Ferriss: The rapid fire, no follow-ups.
Matt Mullenweg: Of different things, yeah, I'm
kind of terrified about going on a show. He's the
reason I started blogging. He was a big influence.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, tell me, I'm
not sure I knew this, tell me more.
Matt Mullenweg: Because he's been doing Marginal
Revolutions for, I think, over 20 years.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: And when I was in high
school, one of the super cool things I did,
you did wrestling, I did this economics
competition run by the Federal Reserve Bank.
Tim Ferriss: Sexy.
Matt Mullenweg: I know. Let me tell you.
Tim Ferriss: You must have been
beating the girls off with a stick.
Matt Mullenweg: Somewhat. My macroeconomic
insights were not quite driving the interest
I hoped for since beginning the
computers and jazz and stuff. So —
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: But we did this
economics competition and it provided, it really
opened a lot of opportunities for me. I got to
go to Washington DC, meet Alan Greenspan.
Tim Ferriss: What does it mean to have an
economics competition? I mean is this
econometrics mathematics competition?
What are we talking about?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, it was
an interesting format. So have you heard of
the FOMC, the Federal Open Market Committee?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Matt Mullenweg: So
that is the committee of bank presidents and
Federal Reserve leaders that come together to
determine what's called the Fed Funds Rate, which
basically trickles down to be the interest rates.
Tim Ferriss: Man, I bet a lot of people would
like to be in that room, wouldn't they? Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: It's a pretty cool meeting.
Tim Ferriss: It must be.
Matt Mullenweg: And they're basically —
Tim Ferriss: That's like the Illuminati.
Matt Mullenweg: And they've been doing an
amazing job too. Think of all the recessions
we've avoided and all the problems they don't
have. So it was, I think Volker who said their
job is to take the punch bowl away as the party
starts going and by turning up the interest rates
slows down the economy. So they have a lot of
levers and some new ones as well. So the first
15 minutes is we would do a mock meeting. So
you would be Greenspan, I'd be Ben Bernanke,
like we pretend role play the different presidents
and we'd read their essays and speeches and things
to try to have their style or their point of
view and based on data up to when the competition
started. So if new economic data was released
that morning, we might incorporate it into the
presentation. So do 15 minutes of that. And
then the second 15 minutes is they can ask you
any question about economics they want.
Tim Ferriss: And do you have to still
be in character or is this —
Matt Mullenweg: No, this is
more that they’re quizzing you as like the five
high school students. And that part was really
fun because it's a little more improvisational.
I love Q and A. And Houston just weirdly ended
up being one of the most competitive districts
in the country. So the first year we just got
creamed. By the way, I went to arts high school.
So we had never won an academic competition,
ever. Like, Beyoncé went there, Robert
Glasper. We weren't known for academics.
But had this awesome teacher, Scott Roman,
who was an economics teacher. He was like,
"Hey, let's do this." So first year we
got creamed. Second year we won Houston,
won the region.
Tim Ferriss: Hold on.
Matt Mullenweg: And then —
Tim Ferriss: So second year
they're just like, "All right, we're giving
you guys all the roids. We're giving you
guys all the specialist top secret Chinese
training programs." How did you just go from
getting creamed to winning in the second year?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, I credit the teacher a lot.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: It was first period,
so it was the same class every morning. We all
picked different newspapers like Financial Times,
Wall Street Journal. We'd read them
every morning. We discussed things.
Tim Ferriss: How old were you then at the time?
Matt Mullenweg: It was high school, so it's —
Tim Ferriss: Okay, 15, 16, 17.
Matt Mullenweg: — 17, 18 probably.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Or 16,
17. He had us teach each other a lot of things and
you really learn something when you have to teach
it. So he'd be like, "Scott or Iram, teach about
some macroeconomics concept," and we'd rotate
through that. And then a lot of practicing. We'd
get together on weekends. Over the summer we went
to DC as a summer program.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: But anyway, got to meet
Alan Greenspan, which is pretty cool.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: The follow-up to that is the year
after there was a conference hosted by the Dallas
Federal Reserve Bank honoring Milton Friedman. And
because one of my teammates had gone to intern for
the Federal Reserve — and actually maybe Mr. Roman
might've started consulting for them or something
like that. I got an invite as a kid. At this
point I haven't done WordPress, I'm just going to
University of Houston, barely passing my political
science major. So I got to go to this and Tyler
Cowen was there, and his blog actually was one of
the big — I mentioned the newspapers, I probably
learned more from Marginal Revolutions than I did
from Financial Times textbooks, etc. And he has
textbooks and stuff. So he was there, and this
is actually, I blogged about this and so it's on
my blog, a post about meeting him. And I asked
him for advice and he said, "Write every day."
And I've basically been doing that ever since.
Tim Ferriss: That seems to have worked out.
Matt Mullenweg: And it's kind of cool also
now that I can look up this history.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. I'm going to do a
bit of follow up on this.
Matt Mullenweg: I have 14
more things I'm excited about.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I know. I know,
I know. We're going to get to —
Matt Mullenweg: This format —
Tim Ferriss: We're going to get to the other
things. Maybe I have an idea for how we're
going to do that. But with the economics
competitions, you said barely passing in
political science. And I know you credited the
teacher and said he was an excellent teacher. But
what was it about the economics, the competition,
the teacher or the combination that made you give
so much to that versus other classes?
Matt Mullenweg: Well, at one point I
got kicked off the team, which —
Tim Ferriss: You got kicked off?
Matt Mullenweg: Which was, it really worked. I get
it now, the psychology of it. So I think by a lot
of ways you would rank things or look at strengths
I definitely should have been on this five-person
team. However, as actually you experienced today,
I'm not always the most timely person. This was
the first class of the day.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: So I was late a lot to school.
And at one point this teacher kicked me off the
team and I was like, "This is ridiculous.
What do you mean? We've got to win. What's
happening?" And then he made the challenge to
me. So his other thing, which was actually true,
I didn't really appreciate this until my 20s,
but he was like, "You have no physical tone," or,
"You don't..." I just thought I was a brain
in a vat. It didn't work out. And by the way,
the school had no gym, we had no sports.
So he was like, "To get back on the team,
you need to run two miles with me," because he was
a jogger. And I think he got me a book called Body
for Life or something, one of these really —
Tim Ferriss: Oh. Yeah, Bill Phillips,
I think, back in the day.
Matt Mullenweg: And so that
was what I had to do to get back on the team. I
had two months to run these two miles or whatever
and I had to show up on time. So I started showing
up on time. And then we did the run. By the way,
I really had not trained, but I just made
it through sheer force of will because
when you're 17 you could just destroy your body
anyway. And so I did that and I was back on the
team. We went on to win all these competitions
and everything. But that was motivating to me,
the harsh consequences, getting kicked off.
Tim Ferriss: Getting kicked off.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah. And also my day
thing at the school was jazz saxophone.
And I think music, all performances can be
very rigorous. You get first, second, third,
fourth chair. You get ranked, you compete. I feel
like that feedback loop and also the performing,
so being on stage, breath control.
Tim Ferriss: True with the
competition as well, like the economics.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, you have to perform.
Tim Ferriss: You're performing.
Matt Mullenweg: When I look back at
what set me up for business later, especially at
a young age, I think it was musical theater, jazz,
performance, that sort of stuff was really huge.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing. So the way we got here,
because I've learned to rewind, you were saying
things should all be automatically linked. Every
mention of Paul Graham in the podcast and
then I mentioned Candyman, Tyler Cowen,
and then we ended up where we ended up. So
anything else? I want to continue to brainstorm
this with you just in terms and we can continue
at dinner just in terms of what experiments might
look like to do things differently where I am
somehow well positioned doing something that
cannot be replicated the next day by a thousand
people. I'm interested in trying to answer that
question more kind of blue ocean versus red
ocean kind of stuff. But let's come back to
your list of exciting things.
Matt Mullenweg: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: And why don't we do this?
Matt Mullenweg: We can go
through some quickly too.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, mention a couple,
this is the process I was thinking of and
then we can dig in. We can sort of swoop in.
Matt Mullenweg: This is a quick one, and
I mentioned already USB-C. If you know me,
you know how much I love cables.
Tim Ferriss: You love cables.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: It's hard for me to convey verbally
how much Matt likes different kind of cables and
containing the cables and organizing the cables.
Matt Mullenweg: And gifting the cables.
Tim Ferriss: And gifting.
Matt Mullenweg: I like to give
someone a good cable. They think
of you every time they charge up.
Tim Ferriss: It's true. I was just
using your external battery pack that
you gave me for my birthday the other
day and I was like, "Oh, Matt." Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: What do you get the
guy who does that has everything the
coolest battery pack, because I've
tested 20 of them. So it's those things.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I know you've put
in the mileage. All right, so USB-C,
Matt Mullenweg: Everything's growing
USB-C now. iPhone is USB-C, I'm down to, I think,
one or two things in my life that are not USB-C
and it's glorious. So I'm very excited about
that. I'm really excited about AI, honestly,
it's the programming of AI, like the prompt
engineering, you can't really call it programming.
Tim Ferriss: Spellcasting. Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: It's like casting
spells. It's ridiculous. And when you
hear a good prompt like you just said,
it's like, oh, that's so cool. And it's kind
of open source-ish in that it's not really,
I guess you could have prepared your
prompts. People do, but there's actually
sites now where people buy and sell prompts.
Tim Ferriss: Which is so cool. Yeah, it's wild.
Matt Mullenweg: So it's kind of like a new
form of programming coming online that,
for me, is as exciting as when I first learned
to program. It unlocks these superpowers and it's
also just fascinating the things you think
would be easy like driving the cars turns
out to be really hard. Stuff you thought would be
really hard, like writing poetry like Shakespeare,
it just kind of spits off in seconds.
Tim Ferriss: Not hard at all.
Matt Mullenweg: Turn this podcast,
make it all rhyme. It could do that
and that's kind of ridiculous.
Tim Ferriss: Kind of nuts. Okay,
so on the AI side, this has, of course, been
a topic in the zeitgeist for a bit now a lot
of people are talking about AI. You, unlike
me, have some technical chops and you know
how to code. I would love to know if you have
any controversial, there's no emotional valence
to this, right? Or maybe uncommon thoughts
around AI or questions that you're asking,
things you're looking for that maybe are not what
I would get in response from a hundred people. I
wouldn't get 50 of them telling me the same thing.
Matt Mullenweg: That's hard. I don't know
what 50 people would tell you,
but I'll tell you one thing —
Tim Ferriss: You get the idea. I mean they would
tell me probably what's in the news cycle or in
the media cycle. Even if it's within the
niche community of FinTech on Twitter,
they would have those inputs.
Matt Mullenweg: I'll tell you
what I kind of hate about it, which is that
it's gotten me addicted to Twitter again,
which I'd broken.
Tim Ferriss: AI?
Matt Mullenweg: AI, because there's the folks
you hear of the Sam Altmans, the Greg Brockmans,
etc. And there's just as interesting and good
stuff on random anonymous Twitter accounts with
an anime avatar. And so it's a little ridiculous.
A lot of the top researchers have these alts,
they call them, or other accounts where they'll
share more stuff and it's redirected a lot of my
reading. I follow a lot of these. Find out stuff
within hours of it happening and they link to a
lot of scientific papers. So this is the area I
don't understand as well. So I've been reading a
lot of papers and learning a lot about it.
Tim Ferriss: Is there a place where people
can find a group or a list of these
people or that's a taboo, right?
Matt Mullenweg: No, no, there probably are. I
don't publish any list. I don't use the Twitter
list function or X-list function. I think Cyan
Banister might. She was very early. She was a
first hundred user of ChatGPT, Midjourney.
Tim Ferriss: Wow, good for her.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh she's definitely one of these
people to follow. Okay, so I'll say Cyan Banister
as someone great to follow.
Tim Ferriss: Cyan Banister,
we'll link to Cyan in the show notes.
Matt Mullenweg: And you find one of these
people that are often a portal.
Roon is another one. R-O-O-N.
He's kind of famous, he also does
a lot of jokes or posting. It's
also kind of funny whole community.
Tim Ferriss: What do you think will
be surprising looking back three years from
now? What will lead most people to think,
"Holy shit! Really didn't see that coming?"
Matt Mullenweg: Next year. So next year I think
we're having at least the 10x in the models in a
way that is hard to anticipate. There's also these
new chip architectures coming out.
Tim Ferriss: Hard to predict too,
not just anticipate.
Matt Mullenweg: Well I think this next turn
we're going to be able to predict a bit. I think
we're going to plateau a little bit after that. So
maybe these are some controversial thoughts.
Tim Ferriss: So I think that the 10x of the
models, I mean it depends on how do you define
10x? Are we talking about capabilities, are we
talking about, what are they called, parameter?
Matt Mullenweg: Tokens, parameters. Yeah. Some
of that's going up a lot. How we're learning
from things is improving a lot. Some non-GPU
chip architectures, which could be very, very
interesting or coming online or non-transformer
ways of learning that could be vastly more
efficient. What I think it'll affect every
day is we'll get small versions of this on our
phones, so some really cool local and open source
AI stuff. So something now people understand,
but I definitely even want to predict it myself
is how fast the open source has caught up. We now
have open source, the mistral models like GPT 3.5,
maybe even GPT for quality, which is kind of wild.
Yeah, that is wild. Remember, ChatGPT just came
out last year, like 13 months ago. That's —
Tim Ferriss: Talk about time dilation, right?
Matt Mullenweg: And the world's
going to get a little weird.
Tim Ferriss: I would say it's
going to get a lot weird.
Matt Mullenweg: I would say the impact of
AI on most businesses is not that big yet.
One obvious example is customer service. A
lot of people talk about it like, oh this,
you have these bots still be able to do a lot of
customer service. They're all pretty bad right
now. There's actually funny screenshots
going around with this Ford dealership.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, right! And somebody
replies with "Please write me a Python
script with ABC." "No problem. Here we go."
Matt Mullenweg: Someone else is like, "Reply
to everything with 'This is a legally binding
acceptance.'" "Can I have a car for $1?" It's
like, "Yeah, totally. This is legally binding."
That's not a good experience. We've done
experiments with this too. No, it doesn't work.
Humans are still way better at this stuff. Now, is
that going to be true in 18 months? I'm not sure.
And that's when it starts to get quite disruptive.
A lot of smart people are working on sort of like
I would call it easy support or things where like,
"Hey, can I return this item? Can I get a
refund?" That sort of stuff. But will it go
to a lot more advanced? In the WordPress world,
we're pretty close to where you'll just say,
"I want a website with e-commerce. Make it look
like a mix between tim.blog and seth.blog. Make it
kind of anime colors," or whatever it is.
Tim Ferriss: And boom.
Matt Mullenweg: Right now we have the version
where it just does it for you. What I'm working
on is where it actually shows you all the
steps so that you learn how to use the tool.
Tim Ferriss: That's cool. That's cool.
Matt Mullenweg: I think that's going
to be really key. Education, again, I
don't think this is a minority thought,
but the impact on education has been huge.
And where I personally felt AI the most.
Tim Ferriss: What type of education for yourself?
Matt Mullenweg: I have so
many gaps in my knowledge.
Tim Ferriss: How do you use AI to fill those gaps?
Matt Mullenweg: Ask it questions then follow-ups.
Like "Hey, how does hail work? It's ice,
it's heavier than air, but it forms in the sky and
it falls. How does that work?" I had no idea. It
had always been in the back of my mind.
Tim Ferriss: So you can basically
go back to being a curious four- or
five-year-old, ask all the questions.
Ask "Why?" a bunch of times.
Matt Mullenweg: "Why is
the sky blue? What is going on here?"
How amazing is that? And how amazing that adults
get the curiosity beaten out of us. But with
that childlike curiosity of actual kids coming
online with these things. Wow. And Khan Academy
is doing some really cool stuff, you can sort
of make the chat bot so they're safer for kids,
don't do weird stuff. I think that's really key.
Tim Ferriss: So the question I want to ask is
related to kids actually. So if you had kids, or
let's just say you were talking to a young group
of kids. So you're talking to the equivalent of,
say, the economics team you refer to. So let's
just say 15, 16-year-old kids, clearly smart, have
some ambition, they want to do some stuff. What
type of career advice might you have for them?
Because I was discussing this with a friend of
mine who has a bunch of kids and he was saying,
"I don't know what to tell my kids." He's a
technologist. And he's like, I think lawyers, he's
like right now we've basically, I can't remember
the exact AI that he's using. It's not ChatGPT,
but he's using a legal specific AI to draft almost
all of their agreements. I don't want to dox him,
so I'm not going to give too much more detail.
But this guy's very smart. He's using that to
replace a lot of at least kind of first round
drafting. Now, there are many reasons to have
lawyers in law firms besides just drafting. So
to be clear, if you need a privatized army to
inflict God knows what, then it's a different
conversation. But then you have many aspects of
AI that are going to disrupt jobs. I mean they
really just are, or people are going to have to
bob and wave. Despite what some of our mutual
friends might say about no one's ever going to
lose a job and so on. I don't believe it. What
might you advise to someone now, and they could
be young or somebody who's just thinking about
a career pivot. How do you AI-proof yourself
or at least put on an eight-point harness so you
have some defensibility? What are your thoughts?
Matt Mullenweg: Maybe this is something I changed
my mind on, but it is one on my list is I used to
really advocate to learn to code. These can
write pretty good code now. I've gone back
and forth. So if you'd asked me three months
ago, I was like, "No, you don't need to learn
to code anymore." Now I think I'm back to it's
worth to learn to code the same way it might be
useful to learn a martial art even if you're
not going to be defending yourself every day
as part of your livelihood. There's something
intrinsically good studying the humanities,
etc. So I think learning to code can teach you
to understand what's going on with computers in
a way that I think in the AI world will also be
very useful. I would tell kids to play with this
stuff a ton. The prompt engineering, the playing
with it, learning how to learn something I know
you're very passionate about feels pretty
timeless. And I'd probably point to that
great work essay by Paul Graham. He talks a
lot about ambition and how important it is.
No matter what you're doing, what's your drive,
how are you going to leave a dent in the universe
or do your best trying? And I feel like that's
really, really, really important. I'm actually
very optimistic about future generations.
I'll tell you something I changed my mind on.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, let's do it.
Matt Mullenweg: We'll jump around
a little bit. It's kind of two parts. One, I
used to be worried that we were going to have
too many people on Earth. Read this great
book Kevin Kelly recommended called Empty
Planet, [which] basically says we're not going
to have enough people. Population has already
peaked in most developed countries. I think
the US is the only nuclear superpower with
a growing population over the next 30 years.
Tim Ferriss: What do you attribute that to?
Matt Mullenweg: For us it's just
immigration. So if we mess that up,
we're going to lose this whole —
Tim Ferriss: Toast.
Matt Mullenweg: It's a big competitive advantage
for us when you think about when the best
people in the world want to send their kids to
school here and stay here. If we mess that up,
I think we have some other advantage, geographic
and resource wise. But yeah, that's a really
important one. I had personally chosen not to
have kids. I think it was seven years ago now.
I decided six years ago. It's like I'm not going
to have kids. The rest of my life sort of built
my life around that. I've been rethinking that
somewhat. Maybe it's the ripe old age of 40.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Matt Mullenweg: Maybe it's also knowing that we're
not going to have enough people in the world. I
think also I'm a bit more optimistic about the
future, especially with the AI stuff that it's
kind of exciting to think someone born today,
in 18 years, what are they doing? For most of
the past hundred years, you could predict a few
things. There's colleges which have been around
for many hundreds of years. There's a few things
that have worked. I don't know if in 18 years,
you have a really super smart precocious kid,
you're going to want to send them to a Harvard
or Princeton or any of these things. I think the
world might have shifted so much that that's just
a radically different thing. That kind of makes
me a little optimistic and curious about it.
Tim Ferriss: What are the reasons do you have
for feeling optimistic? So that's I think
a counterpoint to a lot of the dystopian
narratives that people would be interested to
hear more about. I mean, you're optimistic kind
of by default. Is that fair to say?
Matt Mullenweg: I lean that way.
Tim Ferriss: Lean optimistic to begin with.
Matt Mullenweg: But I sometimes —
Tim Ferriss: Is. This is a big change in the
conversation that you and I have had around kids.
This is my first time hearing about it.
Matt Mullenweg: That's why I told
you I had some new stuff for you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you certainly do.
Matt Mullenweg: For this as well, has just
been inspired. I've now 13 or 15 godchildren,
and so seeing some of them and being able to be
in their lives a bit has been just so rewarding,
so cool to see them download new information, the
whole thing. I mean, this is not novel at all by
the way. Every person I know as a parent has been
saying this, "Matt, you don't understand." I'm
like, okay, maybe I'm starting to get it through
my thick head a little bit. Why optimistic? I know
that technology is somewhat neutral or could be
a double-edged sword. Could be used for good and
bad. I guess I have a core assumption to my
optimism, which is a fundamental goodness of
human nature. And this is actually a big split.
Some people think humans are the Hobbesian life
is nasty, brutish, and short. Or what's the
survival stuff we read, Neil Strauss' book.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, Emergency.
Matt Mullenweg: We're two weeks
of food away from everyone just going crazy. And I
think growing up in Houston through hurricanes and
stuff, I saw some of these disaster situations,
including when there was no power and how people
came together was quite inspiring. So is there
evil in the world? Yes. I mean we see this with
some of the autocratic leaders and things,
but I would, especially of regular people,
not these crazy, evil, terrible people. I would
feel pretty good about being teleported to any
place in the world and talking to someone. That's
kind of cool. And then especially when we figure
out economic stuff and can remove some of
these base level issues, survival issues,
which we largely have in the developed world. And
arguably even in the whole world, the blockers are
typically political or these autocrats, we could
feed everyone in the world easily right now.
The blockers are usually political. That's
exciting. And then the final thing is just
working on it. The best way to predict a future
is to invent it. So there's a way I want the
web to work and I work on it and it's worked.
We got a third of the websites on this thing.
That's cool. And that's forcing the proprietary
people to open up more other stuff. You have a
world view and you interview people who you want
your readers and listeners to listen to because
they'll get influenced by it. I don't think you'd
bring someone on here that you thought was going
to mess up their mind or head them down the —
Tim Ferriss: Wrong direction. I've not been
seduced by the dark side just yet.
Matt Mullenweg: And so that's part
of changing how the world works.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally. And I
do use the podcast for that for sure.
Matt Mullenweg: And the books and
everything. How many people have you met that
are "My life changed somehow?" Yeah. That's
inventing the future. You've just been passive.
That wouldn't have been a ripple in the pond.
Tim Ferriss: You know what? We can look it up and
put it in the show notes. It's not Turing, but the
best way to predict the future is to invent
it. Do you remember the attribution on that?
Matt Mullenweg: I want to say Alan Kay.
Tim Ferriss: Alan Kay. That is it. It's
Alan Kay. What a great line. And how true. What
else are you excited about or have you changed
your mind on? It may come back to the kids thing.
I'm still in shock over this. This is amazing.
Matt Mullenweg: I know. We'll talk about it
more. It's developing. I say, I don't know
what that looks like for me if it's traditional,
non-traditional. But yeah, we just announced,
I just did my State of the Word, which is
the annual speech I do. It's like State of
the Union and it's something I'm very, very
excited about. Next year we're working on,
we're calling it Data Liberation Front.
So basically one reason I think proprietary
services have gotten a lot more popular is they
do subtle things to lock people in. Remember we
talked about the messaging earlier and some of
the CMS spaces like Wix don't even provide an
export. So they really, it's like a roach motel,
you'll check in, you can't check out. So what
we're doing with this Data Liberation Front is
creating an open source directory that provides
two-way like import of all this data. So whether
that's an e-commerce in another page builder,
because of all these different page builders for
WordPress besides Gutenberg, everything. And then
once it's in WordPress, you can get it into
anything else that you want because WordPress
is kind of universally supported our formats.
We're also improving the WordPress to WordPress
migration format. So we have an export, but
it actually isn't great in that it doesn't,
moving the files and the plugins and everything
is still a pain in the butt. So we're going
to make that really, really easy. And so my
hope is by radically lowering the friction,
it'll help make the web kind of force
everything to be a bit more open.
Tim Ferriss: Data Liberation Front. Catchy
name. So it's in a sense, and this may be
a terrible analogy, but it's like
a Google Translate for content —
Matt Mullenweg: Technology.
Tim Ferriss: — management and
technology. From anything to anything. And
then from that next top to whatever else,
Matt Mullenweg: It increases competition.
This also means that if you're in WordPress,
everyone else is going to do this too. But
I think this is ultimately really good for
users. And when you think a lock-in like
music services, how hard is it to move your
playlist in between the music services? Someone
actually built something for this, but yeah, that
lock-in is, I think, not user friendly.
Tim Ferriss: What are some other ways
that you would like to see the technology
world or just technologies stirred up in
this way where if one person or company were
to do X, it would sort of catalyze a bunch
of mimicry/competition that would be ultimately
better for users and humanity/fill-in-the-blank.
Matt Mullenweg: We've talked about messaging.
App stores are opening up now. There's been some
judgments against Google around billing systems
and other things. A big reason I think the world's
strong proprietary in the past 15 years has been
mobile platforms, which are way more locked down
than desktops. Everything has to go through
their app store. You can't just run arbitrary
software on your phone. You'll be able to do
more stuff like that over the next few years.
Tim Ferriss: So could you just walk me through
an example so I understand what you mean?
Matt Mullenweg: Sure.
Tim Ferriss: What it looks like
and what it could look like. So currently what
the issues are and then what it could look like.
Matt Mullenweg: So today, every app on
your phone has to go through the app
store. So they go through an approval process.
Sometimes Apple is slow at approving things,
sometimes they kick stuff out. Tumblr got kicked
out. They typically take a pretty big cut of
payments. They force you to use their subscription
systems and they take 15 or 30 percent of it,
which breaks some business models. So that's why
for a while I think they made exceptions. But when
you subscribe to Spotify or Netflix through your
phone, it would cost more. If you did it on the
web, because they have to pay that cut. And the
exceptions they make are somewhat arbitrary. So
for example, if you buy a book on Amazon, they
don't make you use their payments or take a 15
or 30 percent cut because the margins or when
you order an Uber, they're not doing that. When
you're tipping through Uber, they don't take
a cut, it just goes direct to the driver. But
we added a tipping feature on Tumblr, which
again, we're not taking any money from it,
it's just money going direct between the
people. And they made us charge a fee on it.
Tim Ferriss: Like a surcharge.
Matt Mullenweg: For a subscription.
It was like a subscription thing and they
made us charge a fee and it's like, wow,
if you're charging a $6 a month subscription to
your blog, that becomes four bucks a month. And
then I still have to process the credit card even
or do something else over that. So it just got
very messy. So that's an example.
Tim Ferriss: So that's going
to change, or it might change.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, I think so. I think
regulatory pressure is going to forced them to
open up. You've always been able to jailbreak your
phone or you might sideload things using something
like TestFlight and you can do testing apps.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally.
Matt Mullenweg: But it's not really a
broad commercial thing. I'm also thinking about
this for text. Texts, the multi-messaging app
they might not like. So what would it look like
if it's blocked by the app stores? How can we
still get it in the hands of the people?
Tim Ferriss: Do you have any ideas that
you can share or is that too inside?
Matt Mullenweg: Well, plan A is working
with the networks and just saying, "Hey, we want
to support your business model. We're not trying
to change any of that. We're just trying to
provide this power user tool." And there's a
lot of prior art for this. And email clients, you
can use Gmail with Mac mail or with Superhuman or
any of the other things and their business
is fine. And then two, I guess carrot stick,
I don't know if we have a stick against these
companies, but working with politicians, working
with our user base to do petitions. I don't
know, maybe I'll camp outside Apple's office,
do a hunger strike at One Infinity Way. I really
believe in this stuff because it's user centric.
So what's the thing that gets them to do the
thing that is really right by their users? What
could change? What company could change this all
is Apple. And the reason I talk about them a lot
isn't because I don't like them. I hold them in
the very highest esteem. I love Apple a lot and
they're like a $3 trillion company now, but they
still act like an underdog sometimes. And so I
think a lot about what would a benevolence, elder
statesman of Apple look like if they acted like,
"Hey, we won. We have hundreds of
billions dollars in bank." There's
very little that could hurt them except hubris.
Companies don't die from competition. They usually
die from suicide. And so whether it's flying
too close to the sun or trying to optimize the
last penny from everything in ways that lock
in users aren't freedom promoting, I could see
that hurting them majorly. So I want to see the
opposite. I want to see a really vibrant Google,
Apple, Microsoft, et cetera. And actually
Microsoft is probably the best example of
this. Used to be quite competitive, quite
anti-competitive obviously, and has become
quite benevolent over the past decade and one
of the most amazing turnarounds and runs. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Really remarkable.
Matt Mullenweg: Embrace of open source
making things super user centric. They did a lot
of really cool stuff there. And I think that's
the playbook for all these big tech companies.
Tim Ferriss: What are some of the lesser known
tools of competition or invisible tools
of competition in the sense that someone
or a platform or fill in the blank larger
company making say a messaging service break
five percent of the time or be 10 percent
slower, right? That's an sort of invisible
means of leverage. I would have to imagine there
are examples of under the umbrella term of say,
privacy, you could also see some really incredible
competitive pressuring/crushing/fill-in-the-blank.
So I'm just wondering, as someone who's worked in
technology, understands technology as an operator,
an individual contributor, can code, and who
also is right in the middle of the switch box,
so you see a lot, you get to test a lot that is
behind the scenes. What are some of the lesser
known tools of sort of invisible competition?
Matt Mullenweg: There's a lot of dials. Yeah. So
I'll talk about things that are publicly known
and people have been caught about versus all
the secret things we did. No, I'm kidding.
X/Twitter under Elon Musk got caught. Every
single link you click on Twitter goes through
t.co, a redirect service to certain media sites
and other things. They were inserting like a
five- to ten-second delay. Again, every little
bit of friction, particularly on mobile.
People just press the back button. They go
back to the tweet list. So it's incredible.
And there's studies around this like every a
hundred milliseconds, a page takes to load, lower
conversion, etc. What else has been caught? Google
got caught for, they created this format called
AMP, Accelerated Mobile Pages. It was designed to
compete, make mobile faster. We actually supported
it wholeheartedly and they did it kind of open
source and everything like that. Some documents
leaked that basically said that, and it's funny,
I think the people who were working on AMP
didn't even know this. I think they were
actually true believers in sort of improving the
web type of thing. Certainly we didn't know this,
but there was something in AMP that also
blocked, I'm not going to get this right,
but blocked header bidding or something basically
made it harder for other advertising networks to
run on these pages in a way that benefited
Google. And I think Google particularly
has sharp elbows around advertising stuff.
Tim Ferriss: The greatest moneymaker in the
history of the internet, you mean.
Matt Mullenweg: I get why they,
yeah. And the duopoly there of them and
Facebook, them and Meta is entrenched by
regulation as well. So Bill Gurley has this
amazing presentation, have you seen this?
Tim Ferriss: I'm not sure which one.
I've seen a few of his presentations.
Matt Mullenweg: He has a new one. It's basically
about regulatory capture. The name is a number of
miles, like 27 91. And he goes through a number
of examples. Whether it's COVID test — this is
one example. You go to a Walgreens or CVS here,
there's three COVID test brands and each one costs
like 21.99. This is a couple of years later.
In Europe, they're like five bucks for two.
And apparently the US blocks all the European
manufacturers. And again, these assay tests are
very basic technologies, like nothing new what's
happening there. And he kind of digs into it and
oh, the regulator used to work at two of these
companies. Actually that's interesting. How does
this all work? So how regulatory capture, and he
tells his story of he was trying to lobby around
something and then the politician was like, "Can
I have a meeting?" He's like, "Oh, yeah, I'll come
to you." He's like, "Wow, I'm on the West Coast."
He's like, "No, no, I'll come to you." Set up a
conference room and someone calls, I'm like, "Hey,
we do these like a fundraiser. It's usually like
five grand a seat." And he is like, "Okay." Then
they call him back, he gets six people together,
and then they're like, "You need a bigger room."
All of a sudden it becomes 10 people. Then the
next thing was something like, "We'd love
all the people who are married, for their
partners to donate as well." And he's like, "Well,
I don't have enough seats in the room." He's like,
"Oh, they don't need to come to the meeting."
This is a literal story that happened to him.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Matt Mullenweg: He was fighting for something
really good. It was around municipal Wi-Fi, and
it was being blocked by the telecom companies. The
Comcasts and Verizons of the world were blocking
this. So it's a great presentation. I would say
that's a follow-up for everyone listening.
Tim Ferriss: We'll link to that.
Matt Mullenweg: I think that's also something
that companies can do. I know for a fact they
hire opposition research. They publish. They
sponsor academics and things to publish. This
company's tied up in China or this. It's all
happening to each other all the time. Mostly
among big tech. I would say startups don't do
this at all. Medium tech doesn't do this at all.
Tim Ferriss: Well, is that because they are
lawful good, to use D&D parlance, or is it just
simply because they don't have the resources?
Matt Mullenweg: I would say yeah, maybe they
don't have the resources. My steel man for why the
bigger companies do this is they also get attacked
a lot in probably really underhanded ways. So
it's as much defense as offense. So that would
be my sort of charitable interpretation
of why they do some of these things.
Tim Ferriss: Do you have any security or
basic security or privacy or recommendations
for average Joe or Jane? Well, I guess
I don't want to insult my listeners,
but just somebody like me. I'm not technical,
but if you were to say, "Yeah, one thing you want
to be really careful about is this on personal
devices and computers, just a lot of people do
X. You should really do the opposite of X."
Matt Mullenweg: The easy stuff. Make sure
your apps and operating system are always
up-to-date. I actually get really excited.
It's one of the first things I do in
the morning is load the app updates.
So make yourself excited about it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, very important
with browsers like Chrome too.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, there's a
lot of actively exploited stuff out there. Two,
good passwords. Think you've talked about this.
I like password managers, like 1Password. There's
also this new thing coming out called passkeys.
Tim Ferriss: I have seen this
and I don't know what it means.
So I would actually love a one-on-one.
Matt Mullenweg: This is kind of a new
thing for your audience. If a service supports
passkeys, you should switch to it. So basically
it's a technology which eliminates passwords, use
a secure key exchange, and as a user what you'll
see is that you just log in with scanning your
face or something and it's kind of built into
the OS in a really secure way. It's unique. The
thing that breaks my heart is when people use
the same password on multiple services. Never
do that. All my passwords are super random,
like 40 character. I couldn't tell you if I
wanted to, but you generate them and that's
kind of what this does in a better way.
Tim Ferriss: Do you mind getting into the
weeds for a second? Just on a technical
level, what are we talking about? Are
these kind of private keys and private
messaging like PGP? Am I making that up?
Matt Mullenweg: PGP stands for pretty good
privacy. This is a key exchange. Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: What is that? What's
actually happening? I know this is
probably going to get way above my pay grade
quickly, but password, I understand. Well,
to the extent that I think I understand.
Matt Mullenweg: This is actually, I'm not
sure the exact length of the key or anything
like that, but imagine it like you have a really
unique super long password, maybe a couple of
thousand characters that is then stored in the
secure enclave on your device. So 1Password can
also support these, but basically it kind of gets
people to use random passwords and it creates a
better UI because they're logging in with their
face or their fingerprint or something. So I'd
say that's probably the best way to describe it.
What the protocol is doing is the browsers
now support this as a standard, and so
they do a challenge response effectively.
You've used, like, SSH before, probably.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: You can do
that with a key. So you can type in a password or
you can have a public key stored on the server,
which is not sensitive. Someone could have access
to your public key and not get to anything. Then
your private key, which is secret, and there's
a calculation done between those which says, oh,
this is really Tim or the person with the key.
Tim Ferriss: Got it. Okay. Passkeys to revisit.
What else are you excited about, Dr. Mullenweg?
Matt Mullenweg: WordCamp Asia.
This is actually a joint thing.
Tim Ferriss: Yes. Let's talk about this.
So this is something I am very excited about and
I need to finesse some details to make sure it's
going to work, but what are we talking about?
Matt Mullenweg: We've had some
pretty epic travel adventures.
Tim Ferriss: We've had some great —
Matt Mullenweg: It's been a while.
Tim Ferriss: It has been a while.
Matt Mullenweg: We've hung out more in home
bases and things, but the camp traveling.
Tim Ferriss: We've been all over.
We've been to Vietnam, been to Turkey.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, Greece.
Tim Ferriss: Greece. We've been all over.
Matt Mullenweg: Actually the only time I've set
foot in Taiwan, which is where WordCamp Asia is
this year, was we were connecting to Vietnam.
Actually an amazing story there. A cool Tim
story as well. There was something wrong with
our tickets and they weren't letting us board.
I remember, and this was kind of early,
not everyone spoke English or something,
and you started breaking out some Mandarin.
Tim Ferriss: I remember that.
Matt Mullenweg: And somehow got us on the
plane. I still don't know what you said.
Tim Ferriss: I remember that. God, I
haven't thought about that in forever.
I still have the photograph that you
took in a park late night in Vietnam
of this little kid with a cute hat with
break-dancers in the background. I still
have that on my bookshelf.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, nice.
Tim Ferriss: It brings back some great memories.
Matt Mullenweg: Yes. I've never been to Taiwan.
So WordCamp Asia, March seventh through ninth, you
graciously agreed to come. And part of the pitch,
which also I want to do is take a few days off
afterwards and explore the country. So yeah,
we'll probably get you in on the last day or
something because I'll do a few days with all the
WordPress stuff and then just explore the food.
I've heard so many good things about Taiwan. It's
also one of those places that, kind of like Hong
Kong 15 years ago, maybe you could visit. This
is a geographic geopolitical hotspot.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, there are a lot
of open questions around Taiwan.
Matt Mullenweg: Especially over the
next few years. So I think it's kind of a perfect
time to be there. I would say we got to figure out
what you're doing at WordCamp Asia. If you want
to do a Q&A, I can interview you or give a talk
on something you've learned. It's a cool audience.
Tim Ferriss: It is a cool audience. Got to get to
some night markets. So I don't know if you knew
this, but I've spent time all over East Asia,
have loved my time in Japan in various
parts of China. I've spent time in Taiwan,
most recently in Korea, which completely blew
my mind. Loved, loved, loved Seoul, which is
where I spent time, but I spent, with respect
to Taiwan, specifically two summers in Taiwan.
Matt Mullenweg: No way.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, cool.
Tim Ferriss: I spent two summers.
This is way before tech made anything easy. This
would've been '98, '99, maybe in that range,
somewhere around there. Maybe '97, actually. A
hilarious story. I remember going on these really
rough bulletin boards where English was —
Matt Mullenweg: Physical or online?
Tim Ferriss: Online bulletin boards. The English
was not always super straightforward or easy to
understand. I was doing my best and I ended up
having someone — because I was trying to find a
cheap place to stay in Taipei and couldn't quite
figure it out. Didn't have any money really. So
I ended up connecting with someone who said
they could organize a homestay, and then I
arrived in Taipei. It's pouring rain, I don't know
a soul. I eventually take a taxi from the airport,
torrential downpour, to this supposed homestay
and it's like a dilapidated church. They're like,
"Here's your bed," and it's just a wooden surface.
Matt Mullenweg: Wow.
Tim Ferriss: It's like a tabletop. I was like —
Matt Mullenweg: This is where
your back got messed up.
Tim Ferriss: I was like, "Oh, boy,
I'm really going to have to figure out a plan B."
I had this woman at one point, I was clearly lost,
approached me on the street and offered to help
me, which just due to a host of reasons I was
wary of. I was like, I'm not sure if I want — it
just seems uncommon here for this to be a viable
offer without strings attached. Turned out to
be a good Samaritan. She owned two restaurants
in Taipei. She was like, "You know what? Come by
any time," introduced me to all of her friends.
So I ended up just getting adopted by this woman
and her basically Ratatouille restaurant family.
Matt Mullenweg: That's amazing.
People are fundamentally good.
Tim Ferriss: I am leaning. I do lean. I wish
I had less of this on the Hobbesian side,
so you're a good influence on me.
Matt Mullenweg: Balance each other out.
Tim Ferriss: In this case, absolutely
delivered on that premise and just had
the best time. Taiwan has these fantastic
night markets. At the time, it was perfect
for me because I was such a night owl. Very late
night culture. You'll go out to dinners. You see
this in places like Argentina too, some places
in Europe where you're like, this is bizarre.
It is 11 o'clock at night and there's an entire
family out with even little kids having dinner.
Matt Mullenweg: I love that.
Tim Ferriss: This doesn't make
any sense. Absolutely loved it. I had a
wonderful time. That was a long time ago
now. I'm trying to run the basic math theory.
It's like 20, 30 years ago. This is a long time
ago. For that reason and many more, also that we
haven't taken a trip together internationally.
Matt Mullenweg: In a while.
Tim Ferriss: Like a real
trip. Right? We've collided in various
places in Italy, briefly, like boom.
Matt Mullenweg: That was fun.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, a little
course collision. Although actually I take
it back. Antarctica. That was a real trip.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, yeah, that's a real trip.
That was the last podcast. That was a pretty
deliberate trip. That was a long one, too.
Tim Ferriss: That was a long one. Two weeks.
Matt Mullenweg: Two weeks,
yeah. Was about two weeks.
Tim Ferriss: Exploration, yes, but with lots
of constraints, right? Don't wander off.
Matt Mullenweg: Just a random wanderer.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, don't wander off
and fall into kilometer crevasse and die.
Don't do that. All right, so WordCamp Asia,
what were the dates on that again roughly?
Matt Mullenweg: March seventh to ninth.
Tim Ferriss: All right. March seventh.
Matt Mullenweg: And yeah, Tim's going
to be speaking, so that's exciting.
Tim Ferriss: Love how I keep saying
I need to finesse in the details, but Matt is
committing on my behalf. I would like to make
it happen. Really, this is a priority. So that
is in there. What else are you excited about?
Matt Mullenweg: It kind of ties into that.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Matt Mullenweg: It's something I haven't told you.
Tim Ferriss: Oh wow.
Matt Mullenweg: Which is I am
taking a sabbatical in 2024.
Tim Ferriss: Sabbatical.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah. So Automattic has this
benefit where every five years you get two to
three months fully paid time off.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: A hack on it, to encourage
people to take it, is if you don't take it
until year seven, you don't get another one
until year 12. The clock starts when you come
back from the previous one. I extol the benefits
of this, have literally hundreds and hundreds of
people take them, maybe over a thousand at this
point. I talk about why it's so amazing. I'm the
biggest hypocrite. In 18 years, I have not taken
one myself. Luckily almost every other executive
has. So the example gets set, but I finally
was like, I just need to pull the trigger.
So February, March, April, including during
this WordCamp, I'm going to be officially on
sabbatical. So I'm honestly terrified.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sure you are.
Matt Mullenweg: I don't know how to unplug
for that. You saw me in Antarctica. I got
weird after eight days of no internet.
Tim Ferriss: A lot of people get weird
in Antarctica, in fairness. But yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: So I'm going to try
to do some detox, maybe some silent retreats
working on hobbies, chess, sailing, ping pong.
Just fun to unplug stuff. But honestly, I'm kind
of scared too. So I've got one or two dates that
are in there, a friend's surgery, this WordCamp,
but I'm just going to show up a attendee. I'll
speak or something, but I'm not going to help plan
it or do anything like that. So even we're going
to have a board meeting in there and it's going
to be a good practice. I talked about this with
the team. What are we going to do about this?
It's like, well, I'll go to the board meeting,
but I'll go to it like a board member.
Tim Ferriss: Observer.
Matt Mullenweg: Not like someone who planned
out the agenda and everything like that.
So I'll get the material when the other
board members get it versus the multi-week
period planning process and everything.
Tim Ferriss: So I would imagine you're
generally a fairly important quarterback/primary
actor in board meetings. So who is going to be
presenting this information instead of Matt?
Matt Mullenweg: Leaders in the company.
Tim Ferriss: Leaders in the company.
Matt Mullenweg: Our chief financial
officer or general counsel are always
really big in the board meetings.
Tim Ferriss: Here's a question for you. I'm very
excited about this and I'm very skeptical because
you've already mentioned a number of —
Matt Mullenweg: Things that are in there.
Tim Ferriss: — businessy things that you've
allowed to slide in with some semblance of,
"I'm just an observer."
Matt Mullenweg: Two things.
Tim Ferriss: Two things.
Matt Mullenweg: And it's partially,
I guess I could skip the board meeting. I'm kind
of curious though, for this experience. So it's
driven right now by curiosity. So the benefit,
a lot of people think obviously the benefits
to the person. You get the three months paid
time off. So that's pretty cool. We now have
people who've done multiple because they've
been in Automattic 10 or 15 years and some
of the testimonials are amazing. Someone was
like, "Yeah, I get to take a summer with my
kids," and I think they're doing their second or
third one. They're like, "This is the last one."
So after this, they're going to be in college.
I'll never get this amount of time with them
probably again for a long time. But there's also
a benefit to the organization. It's funny. One
thing people ask because they say, well, do
people just take these and never come back?
That's basically never happened. We've had people
resign maybe once or twice out of the thousand,
but it's very rare. But two, if someone's out
for two weeks or three weeks, you just wait for
them to come back. You don't actually look at the
systems to what they're in the critical path for.
Tim Ferriss: A hundred percent agreed.
Matt Mullenweg: When it's two or three months,
the organization needs to figure out how to work
without that person. So it's a great opportunity
to identify those bottlenecks. Actually,
some financial service firms require this
for auditing reasons. If someone's in a
critical path, if some financial thing,
it's actually a good practice to have
someone else do that for a while.
That's not really our primary concern, but —
Tim Ferriss: You can figure out your bus count
pretty quickly. It's like, oh, wait a second.
Matt Mullenweg: It also gives great leadership
opportunities. So this was inspired by the former
CEO of Automattic, Toni Schneider. He just did
this because he's cool. And he did a three-month
road trip with his family. At the time he was CEO,
I was president and it gave me an opportunity to
practice being the CEO. We saw what worked well
and what didn't. Then also led like, "Oh, we need
to do this executive hire because Toni's really
good at something and I'm not, so we need to hire
someone to fill that in." So these are part of the
reasons I think it's awesome for organizations.
Tim Ferriss: First thought, if you had a thousand
people do sabbaticals or however many people,
but a lot of people do it. Last I checked,
you guys are involved in the content business.
Have you thought of or has anyone assembled,
anywhere, sabbatical best practices? Because
this is also on some level synonymous with
what I described in The 4-Hour Workweek is the
mini-retirement, a primary value of which is
you establish systems and stress test systems
and processes that outlive the sabbatical. They
persist. Is this something you guys have
gathered? Is there some type of discussion
forum where you have anything like this?
Matt Mullenweg: It's so funny because,
as of today, no, but probably by the time this
gets published at automattic.com/sabbatical,
we started working on a page. So a
lot of people blog their experience.
Tim Ferriss: This is a page that other people,
meaning the public, would have access to.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, it'd be just /sabbatical.
So a lot of people blog about their experience
and there's really all types. Some people have
walked the El Camino for a couple months or done
the Pacific Coast Crest thing. Some people just
stay at home and chill out. It's all over the
map. I don't think there's a right way to do it
except hopefully not just do what you were doing
before. We do kind of really strongly encourage
people to unplug. Actually, someone just who's
on sabbatical pinged me on Slack and I was
like, "Don't make me turn off your access."
Tim Ferriss: You need someone to do
that for you. You need to hire a police
officer. So at the end of the sabbatical —
Matt Mullenweg: Put a child lock on my phone
or something and I'll give you the code.
Tim Ferriss: A cookie jar with a timer on
it. The end of the sabbatical, the sabbatical
was a huge success. Why has it been a huge
success? Because there’s doing it to say,
"Look, I'm walking the walk and I did my
sabbatical," but that's not very interesting
in and of itself. It's like, okay, fine.
Matt Mullenweg: Although it
is good to be consistent.
Tim Ferriss: It's good to be consistent,
but you could also creep off to your laptop
and in theory be on sabbatical, but in
practice, be a lurker on all sorts of
different business calls and meetings and stuff.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, that would be pretty terrible.
Tim Ferriss: It would be. So
what would success look like?
Matt Mullenweg: Actually something I'm debating
is I do love coding and computer stuff, and so
playing around with LED programming or something
is maybe a sabbatical project. But I'm also like,
I'm on the computer all day. So just for a health
reason, I think I should really get off. So
what's success? Well, it's kind of what we talked
about for the organization should come back a lot
stronger and people should get a lot more robust.
Tim Ferriss: What's success for you? I'm
most interested in Matt Mullenweg.
Matt Mullenweg: I think for me is that
I'm recharged. The funny thing is people come back
really wanting to work, and a typical thing I hear
is it kind of takes a month to unplug for your
brain to reset. Month two, you just enjoy things.
Like month three, people start to get antsy to
return. I don't know if that'll happen to me,
but that's a pretty common arc. So I hope I
come back with a renewed energy. To be honest,
this last two years has been really, really
hard. We had lots of business ups and downs.
There's been all sorts of crazy stuff,
the AI stuff, and I am a little toasty,
to be honest. Not burnt out, but definitely
at times a little more stressed than normal
where it's really getting to me. You always
talk about how I'm so calm and thank you. But
also I'm human too, so it gets to me.
Tim Ferriss: The duck on the pond,
kicking like hell underneath.
Matt Mullenweg: So I think that's the
thing I'm looking forward to. What am I scared of?
It's a weird thing, also being scared of people
not needing you or irrelevance, which I think is a
really core fear for me. It's maybe not practical
at Automattic, but there's something there.
Tim Ferriss: Is the needing you and relevance,
are those the same in your mind?
Or are those different things?
Matt Mullenweg: They're probably different
versions. Relevance is maybe in a global
context or in the company context and needing
you is maybe interpersonal. So when I've done
some meditations or some other work, that can
be a core fear of mine. Then maybe how have I
designed organizations to need me in a way that's
not healthy? That's one of the questions I ask
myself. Or if you get a lot of benefit, and I do
sometimes — you came in and saved the thing that
feels really nice, especially in a CEO job or a
job, which is very amorphous. People are like,
what do you actually do? Oh, I saved the thing.
But then are you hiring people that need saving
a lot? Or what's the sort of shadow side of that?
Jerry Colonna, who I think you've had on, right?
Tim Ferriss: Oh yeah, absolutely. We
had a great episode. He has some very
good questions. He has some very good questions.
Matt Mullenweg: My favorite is "How am I complicit
in creating the conditions I say I don't want?"
Tim Ferriss: Such a good question.
Matt Mullenweg: It's one of the best ones. So
I think success for me is also just come back
really energized, excited, hopefully with a lot of
inspiration and ideas. I get a lot of inspiration
from art or stuff outside of WordPress.
Tim Ferriss: Recharged. There are different
ways one can use that word. I would imagine
we're talking about recharge physically,
intellectually, et cetera, on multiple levels.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, definitely want to dial
on health stuff.
Tim Ferriss:
What would that potentially look like?
Getting that outside, forcing him to do
a two-mile jog that he actually has to train for.
Matt Mullenweg: Sunlight, nature, nothing novel.
This is all like the basic stuff you talked about.
Tim Ferriss: The basics are the basics
for a reason.
Matt Mullenweg:
And it's so effective. I'll probably experiment
with some stuff. They just started to be this
Blueprint delivery service in San Francisco.
Tim Ferriss: I don't know what that is.
Matt Mullenweg: Bryan Johnson?
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Oh yeah, right.
Matt Mullenweg: The Blueprint system. There's the
weird food that's like a gel or something. There's
now a delivery service for that.
Tim Ferriss: You get your
Soylent Green in a bottle.
Matt Mullenweg: I'm actually
pretty excited about it. It looks —
Tim Ferriss: Why not try it out?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, I'm not really
going to cook this stuff. So yeah,
just do some experiments there.
Tim Ferriss: So I asked you what
success might look like. Made some headway there.
I can ask a million follow-ups, but I'm going to
ask a different question. It's looking at the
sabbatical from perhaps the opposite side,
which is let's say after the sabbatical, you or
maybe just the people closest to you a're like,
"Yeah, sabbatical didn't really work
out. Kind of failed, kind of fell on
its face." What do you think are the most
likely temptations or slipping points or
issues that could compromise the sabbatical?
Matt Mullenweg: Well, if somehow my health
got worse over it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: So a lot of the things we've
talked about and where I find a lot of joy
and happiness is typically in being generative,
making things, not consuming things. But I think
it's very easy to fall into a consumption.
Tim Ferriss: Into consumption, right.
Matt Mullenweg: Like a hedonistic treadmill type
thing. It's nice sometimes. We're about to do the
holidays all times. I consume some stuff, or
it's nice to take a nice meal on vacation,
but if that becomes all the time, we've seen
that happen to friends who've been successful
and typically does not look great. The brief
history of the world guy, the amazing historian,
has a great quote about that.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, you're thinking
about Will Durant.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah,
Durant. I'm going to read it, actually.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. While you're looking
that up, I'll just say I'm interested
in what temptations, because I could
name mine. What temptations you think you
need to be preemptively guarding against,
because the siren song is likely to pull you. How
might you be complicit in creating the conditions?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, social media. I think
I need to be careful about that. Particularly
my Twitter/X addiction, news consumption. My
most dangerous is where something is sometimes
productive or has some positive, but it's
probably net negative on a whole. Or if I
spend too many hours on it. Phone time in general,
I'd love to get down. Screen time in general.
Tim Ferriss: Do you think you could just take your
entire sabbatical off of social media, just delete
them all from your phone, not use them at all.
Matt Mullenweg: It'd be interesting.
Tim Ferriss: They'd still
be there when you came back.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: You know enough
people. If you really were like, I want to get
on the phone while I'm walking outside in the
sun and talk to someone like Cyan or Roon and just
be like, "Hey, would you mind just giving me the…"
Matt Mullenweg: "Can you give Twitter to me?"
Tim Ferriss: The most exciting things going on
right now in your field? I'll trade
because I'm excited to share blah,
blah, blah. You can do that.
Matt Mullenweg: That's a good idea.
Tim Ferriss: I'm sure you could do that.
Matt Mullenweg: I like these ideas. Keep them
coming. Will Durant. This is from Fallen Leaves,
which is that posthumous book. "Health lies in
action. So what graces youth to be busy is the
secret of grace and half the secret of content.
Let us ask the gods not for possessions, but
for things to do. Happiness is in making things
rather than in consuming them."
Tim Ferriss: That is amazing.
Matt Mullenweg: Isn't that beautiful?
Tim Ferriss: That is. Can you send
that to me, please?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: All right. Will Durant.
Was it Will and Ariel, I want to say?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: So prolific and also
so incredibly good at crafting prose.
Matt Mullenweg: Did you read
the Fallen Leaves book?
Tim Ferriss: No, I haven't.
Matt Mullenweg: It's neat. It's on life, right? So
it's kind of his — and I guess it was discovered
after he passed, the manuscript.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Matt Mullenweg: Many years, like 30
years after he passed or something.
Tim Ferriss: Incredible.
Matt Mullenweg: So
I'm calling it the sa-Matt-ical.
Tim Ferriss: For those who don't know, Matt
is a specialist in dad jokes. This began, I mean,
it may have become in the delivery room for all I
know. Okay, we may come back, I'm sure with dinner
we'll talk about the sabbatical more, but in terms
of things that you've changed your mind on or
excited about or absurd things you do, any and all
of the above, you want to do a lightning round?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, I've got some changed and
I've got some absurd.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: Changed, changed
my mind on nuclear, actually.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. From what to what?
Matt Mullenweg: Well, I think even when
I was a baby, my mom took me to a nuclear protest
or something and so as someone caring about the
environment, I sort of assumed nuclear was not —
I was kind of anti-nuclear, Chernobyl, et cetera.
And now I'm pretty fully convinced that it is
necessary, we should be building as many of these
plants as possible and it's going to be an amazing
part of the bridge to a more carbon-free future.
Tim Ferriss: And you see that in small
scale reactors with less likelihood of
technical problems and issues that you've seen?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, all of the above. Let's take
the things that work. They're expensive. We need
to get better at building stuff, China's really
kicking our butt here. We need to stop turning
ones off that we're running. So that sort of
stuff, like stop shooting ourselves in the foot,
we saw what happened with Germany when they turned
a bunch of stuff off, but they're now turning
it back on. So this is going the right way and
there's a lot of investment in the tech here and
so let the Bill Gates startup and the other ones,
and the Sam Altman, sort of let them ship.
Tim Ferriss: And nuclear in this case refers
to fission, we're talking about fission?
Matt Mullenweg: Yes. And there could
be breakthroughs around other things,
but I mean people are scared of this,
but also the US military has nuclear-powered
submarines and aircraft carriers that are
going around underwater. We've done this very
reliably for many decades now. So I feel like
that was a wrong turn in history. Some theorize it
might've been influenced actually by countries or
companies with a lot of sort of —
Tim Ferriss: Vested interest.
Matt Mullenweg: Interest in fossil fuel. But
sometimes we do the wrong thing, then we figure
it out so nuclear is one of them, psychedelics.
Tim Ferriss: Tell me.
Matt Mullenweg: Thanks to you, we
were very early supporters of a lot
of research around this.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, you
supported a lot of amazing things.
Matt Mullenweg: And I felt like especially during
that period where everything was outlawed really
sillily, been very for legalization in a lot of
ways for weed, for example. I think there's some
interesting stuff coming out around marijuana,
which I had kind of not heard any bad stuff about
where like, oh, this can actually create some
risk for psychosis. I used to make fun of these
things, right? The old documentaries were like,
"You smoke one blunt, you go crazy."
Tim Ferriss: Oh, Reefer Madness stuff.
Matt Mullenweg: Reefer Madness, all this stuff, it
was so dumb. But we funded a lot of research and I
like that people are researching these things
so we can understand the good and the bad of
these molecules and how to use them safely.
Because we see the impact is so incredible
and I have now seen, I think you have as well,
where it can go wrong. Super rare, but there's
other stuff, maybe confounding factors.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for sure. So that's
a changed your mind on or modified?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, I think it used
to be very super pro just open legalization of
everything. If you're 18 or above or 21 or above,
you can just get it at any store,
whatever you want, whenever you want,
and now questioning that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I think —
Matt Mullenweg: What's your thoughts
there? You've always been pretty
cautious when you talk about it publicly.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm cautious when I talk
about it privately too. I mean, I would say that
net if you were to talk to say my ex-girlfriends,
I talk more people out of psychedelics than I
talk into by a very wide margin, I'd say eight
or nine out of 10 would be a case of dissuasion
and not persuasion. Simply because, and there are
a few reasons for that, one is if someone's
looking for a quick fix and by the nature
of their questions and requests, it is clear to
me they're almost certainly not going to do any
preparation or integration afterwards, which,
I mean, I often compare to say serious knee
surgery or shoulder replacement surgery whereby
you're going to do a lot of due diligence,
you're going to do probably strengthening and a
number of prehab exercises diligently for a period
of time to prepare your body for the surgery,
you undergo the surgery, which is very tightly
supervised, then you do rehab. And these are all
critical components of the therapeutic outcome.
And I think Gül Dölen as an example, who's
been on the podcast and the potential for
reopening critical windows is a compelling new
theory/hypothesis around some of the amazing
outcomes that you see with these conditions
like complex PTSD and so on where somebody
has the diagnosis of PTSD for 17 years, they've
failed every intervention, and then at the end of
a trial you have something like, I'm pulling this
number out of the air, but it's not that far off,
like 67 percent full remission.
Matt Mullenweg: Where the best other
alternative is like 15 percent or something.
Tim Ferriss: Not even close, they're just
universes apart. But the importance of the weeks
following an experience is one example. So if
somebody comes to me and it's clear to me that
they're like, "What's the silver bullet? Give
it to me on an index card. I'm not going to read
any books. I don't have time for A, B, C, D, or E,
but I do have 15 minutes. Should I do 5-MeO-DMT?"
I'm like, "Absolutely not. No, you shouldn't."
Matt Mullenweg: Well, and so many of these
things are X, Y, Z assisted therapy. And so
the assisted therapy part is really important.
Tim Ferriss: I would say furthermore, there has
been historically, and by historically I mean
recent history in the last say 10 years where
the conversations around psychedelics have changed
quite dramatically. There's a lot more research,
there are many for-profit companies now at
this point, which is fantastic on a bunch of
levels and also incredibly adds a degree of
complexity from an intellectual property and
let's just call it open source perspective
that on some levels can be concerning.
Matt Mullenweg: I see both sides of this
actually because I want some new molecules.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, I'm fine with new molecules.
Matt Mullenweg: Can they engineer something
that maybe doesn't have some of the downsides?
Tim Ferriss: Sure. I'm all for novel innovation,
but people should not be rewarded with
patents that can be used to potentially
restrict manufacture of related compounds
if they're not producing something that
is truly novel with some utility. That's my
perspective. If we're talking about — well,
we could certainly get into this, but there is a
role for new molecules, of course there is. And
if you could take for instance, something like
LSD and modify it slightly such that it is more
of what people might call a psychoplastogen,
so it's not producing a psychedelic effect,
but it can be used in an outpatient setting
for something like cluster headaches.
Matt Mullenweg: Maybe shorter.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, fantastic. We could
talk about this for hours, but I do think, we were
talking about Munger and Buffett earlier, right?
Never ask a barber if you need a haircut. I think
it's very important to consider the incentives
involved when you are looking at the suggested
protocols from a for-profit company. I invest
in for-profit companies all the time, I'm clearly
pro market-driven solutions on a million different
levels and if someone is incentivized to shoehorn
a therapy within currently existing frameworks and
for that reason and many others including, let's
just say, rate of turnover or volume of patients,
they're pushing for an experience that is 10 to 15
minutes in length in Earth time. I have a lot of
questions to ask before I would endorse something
like that. But suffice to say, the conversation
has been heavily biased towards positive stories.
Matt Mullenweg: And I think maybe overly
so because people who went through the
winter are like, "Hey, let's not..."
Tim Ferriss: Easy does it, right?
Matt Mullenweg: And I think I kind
of fell for that a little bit.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, there's a huge
survivorship bias, I think that's going to change.
But especially with smaller numbers and when,
for good reason, people feel like they're
part of, let's just say in the last 10
years, let's just name a time, so 2015, a lot
is starting to happen in the very early stages
like the Hopkins Center and so on, people
feel like they're a part of a movement and
they want this movement to succeed and there are
certain milestones that are incredibly important
and potential inflection points for opening up
these therapies to eventually millions of people.
And they don't want to do anything to
jeopardize that. So if there is a story,
for instance, of someone on the underground
who in a psilocybin-assisted session,
even though they have no outstanding pre-existing
issues outside of say hypertension has a heart
attack and dies in session, that is not going to
make it to the radiowaves, generally speaking.
And there are examples of this, even though
something like psilocybin, there's no known LD50
in terms of lethal dose 50 that would kill say
50 percent of a random sampling of 1,000 people.
So physiologically, it's very well tolerated, but
these experiences can be very intense and they're
not well suited to all people nor all conditions.
Let's just take schizophrenia as an example.
Matt Mullenweg: It's just enough
people do anything, like people die
at Disney World every day.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, right,
right. Yeah, no, exactly. So it's also a case
where if up to this point you've by and large,
outside of an indigenous context because really
in the United States by and large we're not
contending with that, with the exception of
perhaps peyote use in the Native American
Church and so on, but if we're looking at more
Western-informed facilitated sessions using these
various classical psychedelics, you're looking
at the sample size to date, tens of thousands
of people probably who have done —
Matt Mullenweg: That's generous.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, generous, who have done
guided sessions typically at high cost,
often white glove service, let's just call it.
That is not going to be the experience of the
average person if they're going through Kaiser
Permanente or someone else to get MDMA-assisted
psychotherapy five years from now. And when you
go from 10,000 to 20 to 100,000, shit's going to
happen. That's just the fact of the matter. You
certainly see this with any drug that makes it
through phase three and then ends up shipping
millions of pills, you discover a lot in the
process of doing that, and there are interactions
and contraindications that would be very hard to
predict until things are in the wild, so to speak.
So I'm on the same page with you in the sense
that I really feel with these tools, you
mentioned nuclear, I mean our friend who,
rest in peace, Roland Griffiths used to
say that you're working with nuclear power,
you're working with psychological nuclear power
when you're using psychedelic compounds, and you
need to be incredibly thoughtful.
Matt Mullenweg: It's a good analogy.
It can be radioactive, it can be healing,
chemotherapy, and it can also be very harmful.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. And it can be generative
or it can be destructive and plasticity in and
of itself, this word gets used often in a lay
discussion as a net positive, but plasticity isn't
automatically a positive thing. It depends a lot
on what transpires in that window of plasticity.
Matt Mullenweg: That was my big fear. I'm
like, "Hey, I like my mind. I like my life.
I don't want to stir anything up."
Tim Ferriss: Not sure I want to throw
that Play-Doh in the microwave.
Matt Mullenweg: Right? So that's
a lot of my particularly successful friends,
their nervousness around it. And I've also
seen huge positive impacts on many, many people.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. And I think with many of these
things, and another reason I tend to dissuade
folks often is if it's just curiosity, well,
it's kind of like, "I'm just curious, should I
go into the reactor and play with some rods?"
I'm like, well, if you were to then ask, "Is
this risky?" I'd say, "Compared to what?" Okay,
compared to not satisfying that curiosity?
Yeah, it's risky. If you were to say,
because for instance, in the context of
psychedelics, let's just say ibogaine use
specifically, which is very interesting.
Matt Mullenweg: Wow, you took it there.
Tim Ferriss: No, I did, because it has known
cardiac risk, people can die using ibogaine,
unlike some of these more better known classical
psychedelics where there's very low documented
physiological risk. Ibogaine is risky, let's just
say if you're a psychedelic tourist and you're
like, "I just want to try a bunch of stuff." Is
it risky? Yes, compared to not doing it. If on
the other hand, though, you're talking to someone
who is a heroin addict who's living on the streets
who's at risk of suicide or overdose or fill in
the blank, it's a question of comparison, in which
case I think it's an incredibly promising avenue
worth exploring, and there are ways to mitigate
some of that risk Dr. Nolan Williams is doing —
Matt Mullenweg: It could be a shot out of there.
Tim Ferriss: A lot.
Matt Mullenweg: It kind of brings
me to my next changed mind thing, which is perhaps
an antidote to some of this, which is breathwork.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Matt Mullenweg: So I think I thought
breathwork was just kind of whatever.
Tim Ferriss: Dumb.
Matt Mullenweg: There's a million versions
of it and there's apps for other shit,
there's the Wim Hof stuff, there's all
these sorts of different things. Also,
we had a friend from Esalen who's like, "Oh yeah,
all the hippies who did a ton of stuff in the '70s
don't actually take stuff anymore. They just
do breathwork now." And so some of these things
came in from different areas. I've just started
explore it a lot more, it's incredibly powerful.
We've been playing with a shift wave chair, which
kind of coordinates the pulses on the chair with
breathwork. The breathwork is, I would say, a lot
of the benefit of that. And so it's also a tool
you can have with you at all times, you could
travel to any country in the world with it.
Tim Ferriss: It's like with your lungs.
Matt Mullenweg: It's literally the most basic
element of living is breath. And so something cool
if that's perhaps an unlock to a more calm inner
state or access to different things.
Tim Ferriss: So what has been your
personal experience with breathwork?
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, I feel like there's
breathwork that can make me sleepy, I feel like
there's breathwork that helps me focus. I feel
like there's breathwork, it's a Tony Robbins
thing, you do like this. There's stuff to give
you energy. So particularly I'm very interested
in, let me get these words right, endogenous
solutions versus —
Tim Ferriss: Exogenous?
Matt Mullenweg: Exogenous, yeah. So
instead of having another green tea
or something if I'm tired in the afternoon,
maybe what's a movement of breath I could do?
Tim Ferriss: Something internal, yeah.
So exogenous, easy way to remember that
is like exoskeleton, people have heard that,
right? So outside the body, using something
outside the body, endogenous.
Matt Mullenweg: Endoskeleton?
Tim Ferriss: Well, yeah, endoskeleton is probably
what we have I guess, although we just call it
skeleton. breathwork, I would second that and say
that breathwork is something I would view as also
a prerequisite even if your intention is to, say,
ultimately use psychedelics. I will very often
chat with friends who are interested in exploring
many of these different tools and I'll say, "Okay,
first thing you do is you're going to do 30
days of the introductory course on the Waking
Up app from Sam Harris."
Matt Mullenweg: So good.
Tim Ferriss: "You're going to combine that with
reading Awareness by Anthony de Mello. And after
the second week or after four weeks, you're
going to do a holotropic breathwork course,"
because there are a lot of facilitators and it's a
term, turning towards wholeness is what that means
by the way, which is relatively easy to find in
most metropolitan areas. And it was developed by
Stanislav Grof and others. And you should do at
least a weekend course of holotropic breathwork,
ideally do two or three separate sessions so that
you have a chance to have a breadth of different
experience including maybe some challenging
or strange or disorienting experiences. And
then we can talk about potentially phase
two or three if you even need to go there.
And a few things happen.
Matt Mullenweg: It's a
good course just for anyone to follow.
Tim Ferriss: Exactly. What happens in many cases
is people are like, "This is fantastic. I'm going
to continue meditating, and the breathwork has
shown me that I don't need to go to and extreme
altered state, and I actually feel so much better.
Thank you so much." And that's not the end of the
journey, but it's a set of tools that they then
take forth without in any way escalating things.
Matt Mullenweg: It's always with you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It also is just a proof of
concept, I think for me, that if you are going
to throw the Play-Doh in the microwave with
nuclear power, in this case, aka psychedelics,
if you're not willing to do four weeks of things
that will benefit you anyway, you shouldn't throw
your Play-Doh in the microwave because there's
a chance that something will goes sideways or
that you get destabilized and it requires some
really concerted effort with support staff,
some type of safety net to put Humpty Dumpty back
together again. And if you have not demonstrated
the willingness and capability to do that on
the front end, I have zero confidence that
you'll be able to do that on the tail end.
Matt Mullenweg: What would you recommend for
someone going through a deep depression? Because
one of the things about depression is it can be
hard to take a shower, to do that 30 days
of the thing. So do you have breakouts or
things you recommend to interrupt that cycle?
Tim Ferriss: Depression is a multifaceted
beast. And for people who don't have
the context for my entire adult life,
certainly, although the frequency and severity
has changed substantially in the last 10 years,
had experienced extended and extensive depressive
episodes, almost killed myself in college. I've
written about that at some length so if you just
search "Tim Ferriss suicide," that post will pop
up. It's one of the more important posts I've ever
written. It would be certainly top three or so of
the blog posts I've written. Very proud of that
post. I mean, if you look at the comments, you'll
see why, thousands of comments at this point.
But how I relate to suicidal ideation, I think,
can be found in that post. But number one, I'm
not a doctor, I don't play one on the internet,
but I do have a lot of personal experience of
depression, and I've been approached by a lot of
people with depression, including close friends.
And I would say that, as you mentioned, it can
be seemingly impossible to summon the will to do
anything when you're severely depressed. I mean,
there are people who get almost into catatonia.
Matt Mullenweg: I actually this year experienced
it for the first time.
Tim Ferriss: No kidding.
Matt Mullenweg: A very close loved one was going
through chemotherapy. And it was interesting,
it hit me quite hard, which felt dumb
as well because I'm not going through it
myself. But what really woke me up is usually
you hear me talk about WordPress Automattic,
I'm so excited about it. There was a day I
just looked at my computer, I was like, "Wow,
I don't care about this," and that had never
happened before. And that was the wake-up,
I was like, "Oh man, everything seems kind of
grayscale. I feel this apathy." And it really gave
me a lot of empathy for things you've described
before, but I had an experience personally.
Tim Ferriss: What helped you?
Matt Mullenweg: I don't know if my example
was good, because I do want to know your answer.
Tim Ferriss: I'll give you my answer.
Matt Mullenweg: For me, some of
the external conditions changing,
so the chemo getting better and better and ending
was part of it. That's not a great answer because
sometimes your external conditions still suck
or bad things happen. You can lose loved ones.
I got really strict about exercise, I cut out all
alcohol. It's like, "Okay, I just need to detox,
clean up, be kind of monk mode." And I
think that's all I know how to do. Sleep,
I probably uninstalled Twitter at that point.
It's kind of things that are on my list anyway,
but day to day I would say I try to hit a lot of
these things and I'm casual about some of them.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, so I'll make a couple of
recommendations. I am very cautious about
making broad prescriptions because there's
so many different varieties, right? There is
everything ranging from, "I'm having a couple
of tough weeks and I'm not sure why, but I can
still function really well, I'm high functioning,"
all the way to, "I want to hang myself tomorrow."
And those are entirely different species.
Matt Mullenweg: Closer to that first one for me.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, that experience, yeah. So
I'd say a few things, a couple of resources I
want to recommend. First of all, if you're
suicidal, certainly please call a hotline.
And I've been through this, you're not alone. A
lot of people face this and even though it feels
like it's permanent, it's personal, there's
nothing you can do to change it, there are
tools and I'm living proof of that. So I mean,
I am incredibly happy and fulfilled right now,
and I've found tools that help to stabilize and
facilitate that — not 100 percent of the time
because I'm still part of the human experience.
So I would just say, you're not alone. And if
it's an acute experience, please call suicide
hotline, and I'll put that in the show notes.
But if you search my name, "Tim Ferriss
suicide," that post has helped a lot of
people. There's also a post I wrote called
something along the lines of "'Productivity'
Tricks for the Neurotic, Manic-Depressive,
and Crazy (Like Me)," which has been helpful
for a lot of folks. And that also I think just
allows people to remove some of the judgment,
the self-judgment from the experience, because the
experience that is difficult and then there's the
harsh self-judgment that sometimes accompanies it.
Matt Mullenweg: That was tough for me.
Tim Ferriss: Right? Where you might be in a really
challenging state, you're suffering and then you
have this voice that says, "Who the fuck are you
kidding? Are you joking right now? Your life is
great. There's so many people who have of so many
more challenges than you. You don't even have the
right to feel this way. Suck it up buttercup,
get it together," and variations of that,
and it makes it a lot worse. So that post
I just mentioned, which I'll link to in the
show notes, has helped some people with that.
Lastly, I would say if it's really acute, there
are a few tools that I'm hesitant to recommend
because there are, especially in the first, some
risks associated. I did a podcast with Dr. John
Krystal, who's the chair of psychiatry at Yale,
which was effectively an everything you would ever
want to know about ketamine episode. And I think
for acute suicidal ideation and risk of self-harm
intravenous or IM ketamine is very interesting
as a pattern interrupt. And that episode is
available for folks. There are risks associated
with ketamine, there is addiction potential, it
is something to keep an eye on. But again, risky
compared to what? If someone's at risk of acute
self-harm, then it's generally well-tolerated,
meaning it doesn't suppress respiration, it
is very well researched. And that is one tool.
Another, that is a newer tool that
I've been exploring myself also,
which we might talk about at dinner because
we haven't talked about, is something called
accelerated TMS. And this is transcranial magnetic
stimulation. So various types of brain stimulation
for addressing treatment-resistant depression
and anxiety. There are some newer protocols
like the SAINT protocol, which was developed
at Stanford, that are incredibly interesting.
Matt Mullenweg: It's way faster too, because the
old treatments take like 30 days, an hour a day or
something like that. The new ones are way faster.
Tim Ferriss: Way faster. So you're taking
treatments that would otherwise take a month
or two and compressing it into five days. And
fascinating, fascinating, cutting-edge stuff that
I'm paying a lot of attention to because some of
the results are equal to or even greater than with
durability. So it's as fast acting and as durable
or to a greater extent fast acting and durable
than some of the psychedelic-assisted therapies.
Matt Mullenweg: I think about it as well because
we have friends that won't ever take a psychedelic
or some of these things, or actually there's
whole religions, there's Mormons of this LDS,
et cetera. So some of this stuff I
think is a really cool accessibility,
kind of like the same way breathwork can be.
Tim Ferriss: Absolutely. And for people
who might be older, a little frail or with
different conditions, higher blood pressure,
et cetera, a lot of these folks should not touch
psychedelics. They just should not. The risk
profile doesn't make sense. And that would also
be true for certain types of disorders. I mean,
later research may overturn this, but for the time
being, say, schizophrenia, borderline personality
disorder, a lot of folks who maybe lean more
towards the, and this is not a medical term,
but chaotic or entropic disorders versus
hyper-rigidity disorders like OCD, I would
consider chronic anxiety and depression to be also
rigidity issues on some level because they are
often thought loops, things that repeat, there is
a stuckness. Whereas something like schizophrenia,
which I have seen up close and personal, has
a different feeling to it. It's an opposite
end of the spectrum in some respects. So
I'm very interested in those conditions.
Matt Mullenweg: I'll check out those posts.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, for someone who's having a
hard couple of weeks, you mentioned Tony Robbins
earlier, I will mention something that I learned
from him. I don't know if he's the original
source of this, but I used to put this at the
top of my journals, I would write it out at the
top of my journal so that I would see it every
morning. And it was basically, let's call it a
flow chart, that's an overstatement. And it said,
"STATE" in all caps with an arrow that went to
story and then that went to strategy. So state,
story, strategy. And what that's meant to
say is what happens to many people who are
depressed or anxious or whatever is they sit down
and they try to figure out how to fix the thing,
they go straight to strategy. What should I do?
The challenge there is that if you're looking at
the world through gray glasses, the story that
you're going to come up with is going to be most
likely a disabling story and then you're going
to come up with strategies that are by and large
pretty ineffective. If on the other hand, you
start with state. So if you're in a low energy
state, you hop in a cold shower for five minutes,
or you do 50 jumping jacks, or you do 20 pushups,
anything to change your state from a low energy
state to a higher energy state, and that's
governed by all sorts of things — well, let's
keep it simple, so low to higher energy state,
then you sit down and because of changes in
neurotransmitters or any number of things,
you have a more enabling story, right? So you've
turned the gray maybe a tint or two brighter.
Then the strategies you come up with are going
to be more effective. So just reminding myself
constantly before you jump to the strategy, like
the what to do, the how to fix, have you addressed
the state? Because this thing in between the story
really matters, because if your narrative is like,
"Oh, I'm always pessimistic, I've never
been able to fix this," you're starting
at a deficit. You have a severe handicap in
coming up with approaches that are going to
help you. That might be helpful to people as well.
Like state, story, strategy, that is the order.
Matt Mullenweg: I've got to give credit to my
mom, too. She gave me a list of three things
that I found really helpful. She was like, "Did
you sleep? Are you drinking water?" So sleep,
water, and then "Have you been in nature?"
Tim Ferriss: That's a good checklist.
Matt Mullenweg: I like that because it's three.
Sometimes I just do a check. I'm be like, "Ah,
man, this morning is so tough. I felt like I
wasn't grading that meeting." Then I'll just
like can run that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Sometimes the body
scan, I also ask myself, "Am I hangry?"
Tim Ferriss: The basics, right?
Matt Mullenweg: Because our body emotions
come from our system and sometimes it's saying,
"I'm hungry, I'm hungry," and it's coming through
as something else. Our brain interprets it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, totally and to invoke
our mutual friend Kevin Kelly in his book of
Excellent Advice, which came out not too long ago,
great book. Very pithy and one of them
is, "If you don't know what you need,
chances are it's sleep." Or, "If you don't know
what to do, chances are you need more sleep.
If you're in a depressed state," and this is
something I have to remind myself of, I would be
inclined even subconsciously to consume stimulants
because that does change your state. But if you
consume stimulants and then that disrupts your
sleep architecture and then maybe you drink a
little booze to take the edge off because you're
trying to get to sleep. This is a vicious cycle.
I had Richard Branson on the podcast years ago and
his advice was stop drinking as far as depression
goes. He was just like, "In nine out of 10 cases,
alcohol is somehow in that picture," in his lived
experience, in his social circles. Those are a
few things that come to mind. There are other
things certainly, I mean I could go on and on.
I think The Work by Byron Katie and doing
turnarounds and interrogating your beliefs is very
valuable. If you have a belief that — I'm making
this up, but my sister is selfish and always
does what she wants, there are many work pages
and exercises that are available for free on Byron
Katie's websites. If you just search Byron Katie,
B-Y-R-O-N, Katie, K-A-T-I-E, The Work, you'll find
the website. All sorts of PDFs you can take down.
But let's just say, "My sister is selfish. She
only does what she wants." Okay. You would then
create alternative sentences and find supporting
evidence for each one. "My sister isn't selfish,
she never does what she wants," and
you have to come up with some examples.
Matt Mullenweg: With some examples.
Tim Ferriss: You might also replace it with like,
"I'm selfish, I always do what I want," and then
you come up with some examples. I and others have
found these exercises to be incredibly powerful.
There are 1,000,001 different varieties of this.
For me, the turnarounds are, you have to come up
with confirming evidence for statements that were
not your starting statement. I find defangs your
beliefs, which are thoughts we take to be true.
Matt Mullenweg: I like that a lot.
Thing about Charlie Munger, he says
you should be able to argue the opposite
just as well as you can argue your case.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Yeah. When you get thrown
on stage, you've got to be Bernanke. Useful
exercise. Really useful exercise.
Matt Mullenweg: Got a couple more.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Matt Mullenweg: I saw the most
incredible horrifying stat, which
made me change my mind on TikTok.
Tim Ferriss: Oh.
Matt Mullenweg: I'm just going
to read this. It was ridiculous. "20 percent
of 18- to 29-year-olds," did you hear this?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Matt Mullenweg: Said, "Do you agree with
the statement the Holocaust was a myth?"
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Matt Mullenweg: Agreed with it and they
had the chart of the different eras and
like 65 plus it was like zero percent or 0.1 or
something, and then it goes up to this 18 to 29,
20 percent. That's horrifying. Like, oh, my
goodness, whatever has led to that sort of
misinformation and there's some indicators
that it could be sort of TikTok related.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: Makes me really
question is this an adversarial thing? Is this
another country goofing the algorithm a little
bit in a way that is very scary misinformation.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. It's terrifying.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I mean, you imagine
what a geopolitical advantage it would be to be
able to just very ever so slightly nudge sentiment
about X or person Y in a certain direction.
Matt Mullenweg: Our social networks are not
allowed in China.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: There's no Facebook, there's no
Twitter/X. There's no Instagram. I think there's a
reason for that. I think if you'd asked me earlier
this year or something, I would've been like,
"Whatever, we're a free society, we should have
everything, that's dumb. Trump tried to get rid of
it." I was like, "All right, all right," you know.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Now I'm like, "Huh," and it
was that stat that kind of blew my mind. Got
some absurd things.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: Blogging. I think
it's absurd and it's beautiful.
Tim Ferriss: Absurd meaning it's like
the horse and buggy in the modern world
of clips and video and AI? What do you mean?
Matt Mullenweg: It feels that way sometimes.
Tim Ferriss: Right.
Matt Mullenweg: Everyone's on
to something else. I guess newsletters are
kind of like blogging, but you know what,
there's something so beautiful about doing
it. I've been doing a lot more this year and
it's one of the most rewarding things of my year.
Tim Ferriss: What do you find rewarding about it?
Matt Mullenweg: The comments, the interaction,
the follow-up. It's all that. The writing. Well,
the act of writing forces you to clarify your
thinking. It activates something different in
your brain. I mean you know this, I'm
preaching to a writer, a real writer.
That's incredible. The act of publishing is
incredibly vulnerable, scary. Then all the stuff
that happens afterwards, you learn so much from.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, we need to chat about how
to not resurrect, because there's still good
commenters, but how one could create the best
comment section on the internet. Because what I've
noticed, and I'm sure you've noticed this, is that
with blog posts, a lot of that conversation
has sort of left the room to social media.
Matt Mullenweg: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: The volume of comments
and so on is less, but there are exceptions.
If I go to, say, the Derek Sivers blog and I
look at his comment section.
Matt Mullenweg: Awesome.
Tim Ferriss: Amazing comments section.
If I look at Tyler Cowen's comments.
Matt Mullenweg: Pretty good.
Although mixed, there's a lot of —
Tim Ferriss: Mixed, but he's — I mean, I remember.
Matt Mullenweg: He moderates it
and he participates himself.
Tim Ferriss: He moderates it. He moderates it.
Matt Mullenweg: I think that's the
secret. You have to participate yourself.
Tim Ferriss: He posed a question, it was
like the most underrated geniuses of all
time and he nominated Beethoven or I'm screwing
it up, but it was some classical music composer
and there was an amazing discussion in the
comments, which of course may have been,
as I think you're implying, tightly curated.
Matt Mullenweg: I don't know. I think he's pretty
open. But you set an example.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: By the behavior that you do in the
comments and that what you allow, that sets the
standard and people follow that.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Also, SEO kind of screws it up,
because you get people just trying to get links.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: You
really have to be careful about that.
Tim Ferriss: All right, so blogging.
Matt Mullenweg: I changed my mind. Oh, this is
my last change mind. It's a little happier than
the last one. Vienna sausages.
Tim Ferriss: Vienna sausages?
Matt Mullenweg: You know the sausages in the can?
Tim Ferriss: I have no idea what you're
talking about.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh,
wow. There's this thing called Vienna sausages.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: I have no idea if
they're from Vienna, but it's kind of like — how
many? Six or seven sausages and a little can this.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: Pops open. It's one of
those — I used to do it, have it as a kid.
Tim Ferriss: Uh-huh. It makes me
think they're not from Vienna.
Matt Mullenweg: I usually am not allowed
to shop for myself because I am basically like a
kid with a credit card, my parent's credit card.
Tim Ferriss: Gummi bears and —
Matt Mullenweg: I bought a bunch
of Vienna sausages, because I was like, "Oh,
this is going to be healthy." I brought it home.
Tim Ferriss: As an adult, you're saying?
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, this was like last month.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. All right. Got it.
Matt Mullenweg: Because I was like, "I'll
put it in my desk drawer." I like to keep healthy
snacks by my desk and where I work and I just
assumed it's sausage must be like — you know the
punchline that's coming. It's terrible for you.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: You read the ingredients,
the sodium, the everything. It's
like the meat is mystery meat.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: I really thought
I had changed my mind on that. I was saying, "Oh
yeah, I had a healthy lunch in Vienna sausage,"
and someone was a very close loved one, was like,
"Oh, that's not healthy." I was like, "Yeah,
it is," and we Googled it and I was so wrong.
Tim Ferriss: Okay, so Vienna sausage. Sorry,
guys. You're on the suspended list.
Matt Mullenweg: Absurd stuff. Oh, this
is a fun food one as well.
Tim Ferriss: Let's do it.
Matt Mullenweg: There's so much good fancy pizza
in San Francisco, like Flour + Water, et cetera.
One that I really like is called Delfina.
Tim Ferriss: Uh-huh.
Matt Mullenweg: Another thing perhaps with my
Texas upbringing that I'm obsessed with is the
sauce known as ranch.
Tim Ferriss: Ranch?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah. Ranch sauce.
Tim Ferriss: Ranch sauce. Like ranch dressing?
Matt Mullenweg: Ranch dressing. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Uh-huh.
Matt Mullenweg: Sauce/dressing. You
see, this is why you're the chef.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Ranch
sauce. Got it. Okay. Ranch.
Matt Mullenweg: I asked for a ranch
in Delfina and they just scoffed.
Tim Ferriss: Uh-huh.
Matt Mullenweg: I have not
been scoffed to like that in a while. Then I
tried this overseas where there was something,
I asked for some ranch and it did not go
well. Now contrast at a restaurant called
Connessa in San Francisco, a new one.
Tim Ferriss: Condessa? Or Conessa?
Matt Mullenweg: La Conessa.
Tim Ferriss: Conessa, okay.
Matt Mullenweg: They have a lot of ex-Saison
people. It's a casual restaurant, but it's really
good service. They served an amazing pizza. I had
the crust, I like to dip the crust in the ranch.
I was like, "Do you have any ranch?" I was ready
to be disappointed or scoffed at, and he said,
"Hold on," and they actually ran to another
restaurant next door to get me some.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: That was amazing.
But then I realized, because how do you take more
agency in your life? I keep asking for ranch and
being shut down. How am I creating the conditions
I say I don't want? I was like, "Oh, you just get
those packets." I went on Amazon and I got
like 200 ranch packets for $16 or something.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah. Nice.
Matt Mullenweg: These have now arrived
to my place in San Francisco. It's going to be in
my next "What's In My Bag," is some pocket ranch.
Tim Ferriss: Pocket ranch. Yeah, you just
keep one or two in every inside pocket
on your fancy jackets. I've seen you.
Matt Mullenweg: I'm so curious what I'm
going to put ranch on in the future,
having it available at all times.
Tim Ferriss: Wow. Pocket ranch.
Matt Mullenweg: The absurd — I still insist
on looking at every tab and email and
I'm tens of thousands, not hundreds
of thousands behind at this point. I
think I have 500 tabs open right now.
Tim Ferriss: Wait, what?
Matt Mullenweg: This is an absurd thing.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah, yeah. You
have 500 tabs open in your browsers?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: The email thing is like — I'll
even reply to emails from seven or eight years
ago. I have that folder and I go through
it almost masochistically. The sad thing is
on a third of them, it just bounces, because
people don't have the email address anymore.
Tim Ferriss: Why on Earth are you
replying to emails from seven or eight
years ago? Is this just your Opus day penance?
Matt Mullenweg: There's probably some of that.
Tim Ferriss: Just cat o'
nine tales on the back for —
Matt Mullenweg: Wow. I also, like —
Tim Ferriss: I'm not worthy. I'm not worthy.
Matt Mullenweg: I fully appreciated people
who have replied to me when I was nobody
or anything like that.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Matt Mullenweg: I kind of want to pay that
forward a little bit. I also just am really
impressed. I feel like there's folks who —
Tim Ferriss: There maybe a point when
you've repaid that debt.
Matt Mullenweg: What's that?
Tim Ferriss: I said, I feel like there
may be a point where you've sufficiently
repaid that debt that you don't need to
continue to crawl on your knees on broken
glass with your tab of 10-year-old email.
Matt Mullenweg: I didn’t say this was a good
idea. You asked for absurd things.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, I know. This is absurd.
Matt Mullenweg: This is absurd.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Matt Mullenweg: I'm still doing that and yeah,
maybe I'll work on that on my sabbatical.
Tim Ferriss: There you go.
Matt Mullenweg: I'll just answer
emails the whole time.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, God.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, I'm kidding. I'm kidding. I
think you might have some of this as well. I have
a very ultra-critical eye.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: I've been constantly
remodeling things instead of just enjoying.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: They're pretty
decent and fine already.
Tim Ferriss: Yep.
Matt Mullenweg: This is one of those
things that there's a superpower as
well. I can open a web app or a design and
immediately spot things down to the pixel.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: But the downside is
sometimes I go in an apartment that's beautiful
and I'm like, "Oh, next to that speaker,
there's a little divot in your ceiling."
Tim Ferriss: I have the same thing.
Matt Mullenweg: That now you're going
to see every time. No, I'm kidding.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: I just cursed your apartment.
Matt Mullenweg: That
is a curse as well. I'd like to be
able to turn it off to just enjoy
things as they are. The wabi-sabi.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm. How do you think
you'll make any progress with that?
Matt Mullenweg: No idea. Maybe
someone can leave a comment.
Tim Ferriss: I've become a bit
better at this. There are cases where I
succumb to this fine eye for detail, but
I think that — this comes back to the depression
question a little bit. I would push back on the
idea that some of the interventions I mentioned,
like 30 days of meditation are out of reach for
people who are having a hard couple of weeks.
I would say that the returns on something,
and this is very simple. Number one, the social
return on, say, going to a weekend transcendental
meditation training, interacting with someone
is net positive to begin with. So I'm assuming
you can get out of bed. If you're crippled
psychologically and can't get out of bed,
then it's a different conversation. But if you
can get up and you're just like, "I really just
don't know what to do to get out of this funk,"
meditating twice a day for a week, I would say
in the vast majority of cases, 20 minutes a
session twice a day will make a difference.
It creates a bit of space in the system and a
little bit more space. It's like taking your
thought speed down to 0.5 X, so that there's a
little bit more space for you to become aware
of the stories and the voice and so on. But
honestly, just slowing down, which for me,
meditating twice a day does, more than half of
the time, I wonder if the benefits that I get from
it are just not doing anything for 20 minutes.
I could just lay down on the floor for 20 minutes,
but proving to myself that I do not need to rush.
I have enough time. I have the luxury of being
able to take two 20 minute breaks and then seeing
over the course of the week that, "Oh, I actually
get better results with less stress when I do
this." Sometimes I think it's just sitting up
straight with good posture for 20 minutes.
Matt Mullenweg: Mm-hmm.
Tim Ferriss: I don't know what the causal factors
are, but I do think there's a benefit there. I'm
bringing it up because I do think that a regular
meditation practice has helped me to accept some
of the wabi-sabi stuff and where there's a
point of diminishing returns where there's
improvement up to 90 percent right.
Then if you want to improve it from
90 percent right to close to a hundred percent
right, first of all, you're almost never going
to get to 100 percent, because things change and
things deteriorate. I'm making up a number here,
but let's just say it takes you five hours or
50 hours to get to 90 percent right, it'll take
another 50 hours to do the last 10 percent.
Matt Mullenweg: It's actually, that's very
different from my experience of meditation.
Tim Ferriss: All right, tell me. You become —
Matt Mullenweg: This is actually — it's something
I've changed my mind on. We're going to have to
talk at dinner, because I —
Tim Ferriss: You've become more monkish?
Matt Mullenweg: Well, no. I think meditation can
actually be dangerous at certain levels. That's
something we have to explore.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm. Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: But for me, and maybe it's how I'm
meditating as well, my system gets very sensitive
and very observant.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah?
Matt Mullenweg: I also probably try to use
meditation a little bit as a mental exercise,
improve my cognition, my focus, other things.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: That focus as well, can sometimes
or just the sensitivity to the system, talking
about downsides of meditation, I know someone who
loved blueberries and they got so sensitive to
their system they can't eat blueberries anymore.
Tim Ferriss: From meditation?
Matt Mullenweg: That's what they claim.
Tim Ferriss: Wow.
Matt Mullenweg: There's the pursuit of the Jhanas,
which is really big in San Francisco now.
I've got to catch you up on a bunch of
weird San Francisco stuff.
Tim Ferriss: All right,
so we'll get caught up on the weird San
Francisco stuff. I did just do an episode,
which didn't get as much attention as I would like
it to get, but I did an extended episode with Dr.
Willoughby Britton I'll put it in the show notes
on the hidden risks of meditation, actually.
Matt Mullenweg: Oh, cool. I'll check that out.
Tim Ferriss: How they're addressed and how they
overlap with a lot of the risks of psychedelics.
Matt Mullenweg: I believe that, yeah.
Tim Ferriss: Which is not to say like —
Matt Mullenweg: Don't do it.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, a boogeyman in the closet,
like you're going to do TM for 20 minutes and
have your brain implode. I'm not saying that.
Matt Mullenweg: Not so that — the dose of that is,
I think extremely low risk.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: I'm thinking more
like, yeah, many hundreds of hours.
Tim Ferriss: Then you get into trickier territory.
I mean, historically, it's not like everybody
in the world was on meditation apps. Meditation
was reserved for a pretty select group of folks,
who had a lot of supervision. 20 minutes
though, twice a day I find helpful. For example,
a mutual friend of ours was at my house recently
and for whatever reason, I'm in an older house
and there are 87 light switches. There's so many
light switches, it's so unnecessary. There's one
panel with the switches that is like 10 percent
turned. He doesn't have the fixation on details
that I do. But he said to me, he's like, "I'm
astonished that you have not fixed that because
that must drive you insane." He's known me for
a very long time. I was like, "Yeah, this is my
daily practice is to look at that."
Matt Mullenweg: That's cool.
Tim Ferriss: And be like, "You know what,
it's fine. It's fucking fine." There are
many other bigger fish to fry. That in
a way kind of becomes my practice. It's
in the kitchen. I see it every day and it's
gotten to a point where it doesn't bother me.
Matt Mullenweg: Well, and if or when we
have kids, I think kids also break it up.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, they're
going to break everything.
Matt Mullenweg: Any obsession you have
with keeping your house perfect I think
goes out the window.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, yeah,
yeah. It's going to be game over.
Matt Mullenweg: I'm almost done.
Tim Ferriss: All right, what you got?
Matt Mullenweg: This last one is really
weird and then I have a funny one.
Tim Ferriss: All right.
Matt Mullenweg: The weirdest thing I've been
exposed to recently, Scott Alexander actually
wrote about it, but have you heard about
this bacteria you put in your mouth and it
eliminates cavities?
Tim Ferriss: No.
Matt Mullenweg: Okay, so we have bacteria in
our mouth. It's a whole microbiome, right?
Tim Ferriss: Yes.
Matt Mullenweg: I guess there's a
mutation on one of the bacteria that they
have essentially GMOed a replacement.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm. Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: The bacteria, I guess,
normally produces lactate acid.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: The lactic acid is what
breaks down your teeth, creates cavities.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: In the '80s, I guess the
scientists discovered this in one of his student's
mouth. It had two mutations and they genetically
modified it to add a few more. Basically one,
instead of lactic acid, it'll produce alcohol.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: Really trace amount.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: This is
not even one drop, but it's —
Tim Ferriss: It's not like
a whiskey distillery in your mouth.
Matt Mullenweg: You're not getting drunk from
having this bacteria. I forget the second one.
The third one was basically something where it
won't share this mutation with other bacteria. It
takes out the thing that usually allows bacteria
to trade stuff. There was a fourth one. I don't
know, we're going to have to look it up now,
because I've forgot two of the four things.
But you get a one-time treatment of this. You
basically scrub your teeth a lot. You put in this
new thing, it takes over. Oh, it takes over from
the old version of this bacteria, and that becomes
the dominant bacteria in your mouth. It doesn't,
if you kiss the friend or something,
doesn't spread because they would need
to have their mouth existing stuff removed
first before the new thing could take hold.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah. Their parking spots are full.
Matt Mullenweg: The parking spots are full. I
guess the story is this guy tried to get it FDA
approved, a scientist, and he created a company
around it. The FDA was like, "You need to test
this on 100 children or 100 people who live more
than — 100 people under 30 who have dentures,
who live more than five miles from a school or
something like that.
Tim Ferriss: What?
Matt Mullenweg: They created
this really messed up thing.
Tim Ferriss: Weird.
Matt Mullenweg: It was basically impossible.
Matt Mullenweg: Some
hackers heard about this story. First they
tried to clone it, then they partnered with
the guy to get the formulation, and they're
doing it down in Central America someplace.
Tim Ferriss: What?
Matt Mullenweg: There's this libertarian.
What's the name of that city that they created?
Tim Ferriss: Oh, it's —
Matt Mullenweg: The crypto libertarian one.
Tim Ferriss: It's like a crypto libertarian
thing in El Salvador or something.
I'm blanking on the name.
Matt Mullenweg: It's called Lantern Bioworks.
Tim Ferriss: Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: I have no association,
not an investor or anything.
Tim Ferriss: No. Okay.
Matt Mullenweg: I'm thinking
about trying this. It's a little absurd.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. Lantern Bioworks.
Matt Mullenweg: You go down, you get the
treatment, a one-time thing. I guess when
they're bootstrapping, the company
will be expensive, like $20 grand.
Tim Ferriss: How are they in Central America?
Matt Mullenweg: The goal is to make this a
couple of hundred dollars. Oh, because this
libertarian city has anything a consenting adult
wants to do for a biotreatment, you do.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: As long as you're informed of the
risk. The other thing, they're going to hopefully
commercialize it so they can make it $200.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Then finally they'll
try to bring it back to the US. I guess
it's different regulations around
probiotics. Have you tried ZBiotic?
Tim Ferriss: I have, yeah. I tried it
this past, I guess maybe six months ago.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I did not find it. This is to prevent
hangovers? This is what we're talking about?
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah. It helps metabolize the
alcohol in your stomach.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah.
Tim Ferriss: I did not see
a huge difference personally, but maybe
I wasn't consuming enough. But yes,
I know what the product is.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, so same
idea. That's A GMO biotic.
Tim Ferriss: I know people
who swear by it, but for me it —
Matt Mullenweg: I brought some just in
case this was going to be one of those podcasts.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, good. Good. Well, look,
I'm always up for a second ride at the rodeo.
Matt Mullenweg: Yeah, there's a different
regulation around these probiotics.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: If they can kind of
get it reclassified as a probiotic,
I think they can maybe bring it to the US.
But how cool that may be in the future,
we won't have cavities anymore? Because this will
just be something we give to kids as soon as they
start to develop teeth.
Tim Ferriss: Wild.
Matt Mullenweg: Then how cool would that be?
Tim Ferriss: Uh-huh. Yeah, wild.
Matt Mullenweg: That's my weird thing.
Then my funny thing is, this is also my
"What's In My Bag" post, but it's a little
device, USB-C of course. You never know when
you're going to need a party, so it plugs in.
Tim Ferriss: This is like a disco ball that plugs
into the bottom of your iPhone.
Matt Mullenweg: USB-C.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah, USB-C. That's amazing.
Matt Mullenweg: You can get adapters for lightning
and different stuff. But yeah, especially
with the holidays coming up, New Year's.
Tim Ferriss: That's fun.
Matt Mullenweg: Just a little pocket party.
Tim Ferriss: Yeah.
Matt Mullenweg: This is so fun.
Tim Ferriss: That is super
fun. Amazing. That's awesome.
Matt Mullenweg: This is $3 or something.
Tim Ferriss: What would someone
search to find that?
Matt Mullenweg: It's
on my post. The "What's In My Bag" post.
Tim Ferriss: Okay. We'll link to that.
Matt Mullenweg: And I think this
was like USB disco light that I saw.
Tim Ferriss: Literally you could hold it, you
could cover the whole thing in your hand. It's
very small, but it does look pretty much exactly
like a disco light, with USB-C that you plug —
Matt Mullenweg: That one's now for you.
Tim Ferriss: Oh, thank you.
Matt Mullenweg: Merry Christmas.
Tim Ferriss: Merry Christmas. Merry
Christmas. So great to hang, man.
Matt Mullenweg: Likewise.
This has been a lot of fun.
Tim Ferriss: Always, always a
great time. We're going to head out, grab a bite
to eat. We'll continue the conversation. Anything
else you'd like to add before we wind to a close?
Matt Mullenweg: No. Photomatt, P-H-O-T-O-M-A-T-T.
Tim Ferriss: Mm-hmm.
Matt Mullenweg: All the
socials. But really check out my blog, ma.tt.
Tim Ferriss: Ma.tt We will add everything we
talked about to the show notes, so folks can
peruse all of these things. There's going to
be a lot at tim.blog/podcast and search Mullenweg.
I should probably come up with a more elegant way
of directing people to specific episodes.
But if they search you, you've been on a
bunch. Just look for the most recent episode,
assuming that you're not listening to this a
few years hence. As always, till next time, be
just a little bit kinder than is necessary. Not
just to other people, but to yourself.
Remember that, Jack Kornfield. If your
compassion does not include yourself, it is
incomplete. As always, thanks for tuning in.